tout ce dont une femme magnifique match
de speechless juniors ce soir ouais avec
une confrontation j'ai envie de dire
italo iranienne bah ouais donc bon je
sais pas ce garçon donc on va pas le
dire mais il est champion du monde
junior qu on peut dire par am peut-être
pas mais c'est quoi son prénom on pas
c'est son prénom elle je crois et donc
je touche quoi
mitroglou mitroglou un peu en quelque
sorte comme un oeil mais attends je vais
regagner bientôt pour nom l'année ils
menacent d'être champion du monde a à
chaque segment non vie s'ils sont très
aléatoires par jour il échoue quoi mais
jamais je n'ai pas besoin d'entraîneurs
qui dit qu'ils étaient très forts en
fait max ou de louhans fait à toulouse
montre le nôtre à nick matthew mc shane
mitroglou vans et puis en fait match nul
ou de presque 2 au jeudi où on iranien
ce qu'on a des irano piquant je sais pas
quoi dire
here in a row ira sauf own perçoit là
ouais je sais pas vous virer je vous
dirai si j'ai un avis perso phone perso
phone moi je lance le twitch de chat
je montre un gros noob chatou si je suis
en train de tout lancé je suis en train
de lancer qui a lancé quoi voilà ça
c'est fait je crois qu'on est bons rails
et les gens qui écrivent salut taille
comme chez lise et j'étais ballon on est
en pré match et j'installe le nouveau
gange en ce moment donc j'ai passé un
long moment dans le nouveau gange
mais en fait j'ai l'impression que les
précédents locataires du charançon que
c'était vraiment un camp en fait c'était
des cousins de polo j'ai l'impression
si je perds on a tout nettoyé à fond et
tout état est encore une petite odeur
quoi qui parfois tu pars pas tout sinon
avec en aérant et tout ça ça s'en va
mais mais juste j'ai senti avec le
réfrigérateur en fait en faite le
le ch est un nouveau jeu sera nettoyé à
fond mais ce que j'ai adoré c'est dans
le dans le congèle en fait il y avait
des petits résidu d'os qui avait pourri
ou juste pas quoi tu vois qu'il était au
bout de tes cachets cacher c'est ce que
je suis c'est génial quand ça doit être
un grange non contrôlés peut-être on
sait pas quoi ne vérifie dans tous les
recoins peut-être son cachet des bouts
d'os tech qui pourrissent avec le temps
quatre anneaux d'or horrible hayat avec
le combat est le combat c'est ce que je
sais déjà pour enterrer ses morceaux de
poulet je sais plus mais oui c'est pour
pas que ces deux sphères il avait acheté
le sepa de la terre non mais c'est vrai
si tu peux tu peux rajouter dans tes
plantes s'appelle pas de la terre c'est
du terreau non pas du terreau à tout
même si ça c'est le terreau de la bonne
terre l'autoroute est une terre très
noir très plein d'eau minéraux quoi donc
tous tes plantes sous trésor je vois
pourquoi tu interdite pour les deux noms
pourquoi c'est pas que ça prenne
l'auteur en fait je crois que ça c'est
parti femme en fait oui c'est parti
c'est une anglaise s'est en rien à dire
c'est globalement quand même très
favoris quoi par amagou à ma gauche ou
naïve menacé tout le monde gagner le
match
d'ailleurs les l'algorithme et 12% à
moroni quoi je pensais vraiment qu'une
chanson ready valeur se faire défoncer
c'est génial on va voir on passe une
petite vente solides annonce sky ou cinq
de ses huit y est tu veux faire pousser
6 après ça tu veux faire passer s'ils se
dire avec la cie ont tous les soirs avec
les noirs mais dans le monde paye ou 5
c'est le gros coup en attaque besson
comme suit défend l'option y avait pas
une partie gritche ou qu'on avait fait
tout ça a été assez à la mode ce truc en
fauteuil voilà mais je passe à vue
aujourd'hui dans un grand prix féminin
ya vlad qui a commenté un petit peu
pendant une heure le candidat ouais non
je connais bien fourni commenter ou avec
mir onichtchenko était là n'était pas
avec une boutade pour compte non
malheureusement
mais peut-être qu'il est déconnecté
parmi ces pronostics a tant fait voire
surréaliste c'est encore la cam non issu
ni su
non il est connecté mais pourquoi
l'issue de quoi bailly se tient la tête
c'est génial qu'est ce que je vais jouer
la demie coulisses il raconta dans le
live un chien j'ai regardé j'arrivais 5
10 minutes un comme ça vous avez parlé
de double fiançailles faisait que des
échecs quoi ces jeunes et rester dans
lequel chacun des quatre donc des quatre
pieds je connais pas trop je pense que
si ça se trouve
jouable il a tellement réfléchi se
retisser retenu la tête et tout genre
j'ai su m et j'ai trouvé le bon coup
enfin il était très heureux des hommes
pourquoi pas il tente un truc parce
qu'elle est aussi notre gamme très
solide pour les dans le top 6 buts et
compagnie tu vas prendre la paire de
fumay notre côté c'est première partie
du match mais il a le temps de me as
marrant même du coût des quatre contes
reçu un amour ni reçu est issu à fond il
fonde et est un peu bizarre en fait les
deux je n'ai pas faim moroni suisse bâle
enfin chez vacheron prend pas en fait en
tête mais je pense que vous laissiez
secours permanent moroni et il y jouant
avec le casque c'est ouais les oreilles
et le game music et par rame pas du tout
nous parlons trop son truc il est une
tête assez assez assez cylindrique par
amer non c'est de l'eau issue mais j'ai
compris à quoi c'est fantastique de
musiciens ont reçu je vois cet autre
ouais c'est génial non issue a reçu à
200% voilà un début de match assez bas
c'est sûr on m'a fait comprendre que je
ne sais pas quoi dire enfin c'est très
bizarre comme en début de match et on va
vous la v6 ok va pas fêter ici trois
peut-être non pas l'europe notre
possible où il a fait donc qu'ils
essaient 3
oui fff est un fait des coups en fait
lâché match ce que non en fait ça a
l'air tellement insipide comme position
ils ont l'air à l'est de sua fonds vaf
pas si seulement avec des soucis c'est
peut-être qu'il ya quatre ans faire suer
tu vas faire d'un bekkat échec t'échange
vous bouffez ceinture
tu veux rester ici de quand même enfin
moi je veux bien mais enfin comment tu
empêches non mais peut-être qu'ils se
situent fait d'avoir dépensé je sais pas
oui on apprend enfin j'ai changé là on
n'échange pas oui oui faf
j'aime au fond j'ai deux très profonde
et 7 on verra bien ce qui se passe que
oui cette au québec 4 et 5e michael six
mois je pensais que c'était mauvais mais
je lisais peut-être car a lieu cinq
classes soit mais ont peut-être la pure
prend des quatre noms ca / - c'est là
tout d'un coup ils ont une minute chacun
on se retrouve rsa est très intéressant
pour la suite
à roques
qu'est-ce qu'ils le pays sauf sont pas
feints qui n'est pas là
en tout cas ils ont ils ont mis par à
main sous la caméra de mag ou douces ou
quoi aïe
ceux ci se mettent pas du tout rond en
fait les convois ne peut pas dire bon
rock nord que moi ces crimes au nom de
suture d'artois ça va encore il y arrive
bon alors comment ils continuent avec
les noirs fab pas je n'ai pas pu en
prendre soin tour c'est 8 soit poussé 6
sauf le 7d plein de coups bas à tour ses
8 mai du christ que toi tu es plus fort
que moroni où pas bougé moins de velours
tu as moins de vélo quand même il amusé
que toi maintenant ces foules médaille
jouer contre lui non ouais j'avais perdu
qu'une pièce de plus mais je rappelle
cette partie mais tu l'avais
complètement dominé non non mais il a
fait le court je peux pourquoi je pense
qu'il a peu vu ou rien
je vois cette sortie peut-on pourri
mauvaise partie des noëls le de tout le
monde pour l'entrée au caire il va
peut-être mal quoi rock et 17 si on
prend aussi sa oui non peut contrôler
tout ça me fout totti prénoms des cinq
spots elle non plus mais j'ai
l'impression que parham a bien joué il a
quand même fait pendant à sculpter de
choses et d'autres par am
il a fait le boulot là mais c'est
byzance dont une montre qu'outre qu'il
ya six nouveaux choqué jeudi apa le
centre avec le gagnant n'est qu'à 6 ça
va j'ai pensé ça m'a effleuré l'esprit
je dis non je ne vais pas en parler
parce que le coup a l'air très mauvais
enfin pas tous cavaliers palmarès quand
même je contrôle a cassé 5 enfin je suis
pas non mais en fait tu joues avec une
pièce de basse et non mais je trouve
bizarre que deux jeux amoureux de la
chose qui va se faire écraser un web
affrontera dans le match aussi mais bon
normalement l'autre est plus fin elle a
quand même 300 points l'eau de pluie sur
de chasse comme par am c'est pas
négligeable et j'ai envie de te dire il
à 150 points de plus et louhans fidh et
il est champion du monde junior il a un
petit palmarès que ouais ouais
après skis pour as qu au prochain tour
il joue contre sarah l'a donc à mon avis
bon enfin fini comme wes et ils vont il
n'aura aucune chance mais mais bon il
peut passer un tour quoi je ne sais qui
est comme ça la théorie oui après des
quatre c'est fou ces six le beaucoup
joué par tous les mecs à rognan un an
d'arrêt krishna même cornouaille à
l'époque ça reach adams et à la joue un
peu bizarre finale 2006 et d'os et celle
où ben ça existe un peu y'a pas de
raison de faire en fait parce que alors
attends là il va il va perdre le pion
réussissant force donc avalé à quatre
dames la foule 4 et y'a quoi il ya un
cheapos où il ya vous prend 17 aussi
qu'il y aille non non mais oh tu perds
tout est prêt en mai c'était hier au f4
et foulé cette taille c'est fini ouais
voilà tant qu est-ce que votre a troqué
d'entreprendre la petite tour
il faut être quatre man en mai puis et
puis tout va bien quoi je m'attendais à
n'importe quelle heure en l'air manqué
ses trois tu pourrais aussi faire
tourner en apprend un cadre d'un projet
six échecs un mois ne l'avais pas vu
j'avais peur bien que le dépôt ben tu
avais pas fait un cahier pour rien bon
là le match fab moroni ne conteste plus
rien du tout la noix et doit abandonner
le 4 janvier c'est ok les gars devant
son fils je me paraissent qu est ce que
la stratégie c'est peut-être pas de ne
pas abandonner pour que le minimum deux
parties possible je vais toujours
jusqu'au bout si tu commence déjà à
gérer je sais pas je sais pas ce que
c'est la stratégie s est tu t'es dit
façon je vais perdre tu géré le score
oui je veux pas me faire adopter quoi je
vais faire durer le plus longtemps
possible
ouais je ne jouais pas dix parties dans
ce match tellement mal fait pas ses
qualités de moins structure de pions
pour ifa ça se joue pas n'en fasse pas
ce qui est des viandes l'état zéro
augmentation des antilles compensation
aux côtés même sans médaille en deux
mois tout ce que moi même je fournis un
petit coucou à me pousser un histoire de
turf
je range mes pièces dégage c'est quoi le
spcj speech s junior ouais j'étais seule
chaîne anglaise - top ce qui s'il met
tout à fait faux tous venir là monsieur
vous parlais pas français
beaucoup plus pédagogiques encore
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas trop de peine
pour le moment fable mais c'est parce
que
en fait ce match là c'est lions de
beauce sud ouais en fait le maintenant
on va on va dire on va dire la vérité
femme parce qu'on dit toujours la vérité
mais qu'en fait le match on sent pas
trop honnêtement nous soyons honnêtes le
sait pas c'est pas qu'on n'aime pas les
joueurs ou quoi mais c'est non mais
c'est premier tour d'un grand chelem
talent mais qui est fou c'est pas moi
90e mondial convainquez une wild card
qui est qui et 800 50e mondial qui a
jamais rien fait dans sa carrière tu
vois ça sent quand même le 6-0 6-1 6-2
tu as envie de te dira encore le lait
les deux jeux tu as marqué c'est
vraiment parce que parce qu'il fallait
pas te mettre six heures 6 heures 6
heures ne peut pas un bon service du
tramway par jeu tu sues métier en feu
mardi et justement il a rien à perdre il
ya tout lieu à tout donner
ouais en fait il est nul c'est surtout
ça le problème pieds nus le bas à moroni
par rapport à par rapport à apparemment
par rapport à par ammann web ont eu la
foi c'est un grand mot mais oui fait des
mois encore non mais vraiment rapport
gérant je ne dis pas fondamentalement il
faut bien il est grand maître il joue
bien mais géré par rapport à part âme
ouais bon en fait je connais pas trop ce
soir 20 je sais qui bon j'ai vu son
interview bon je fais 20h d'échec par
jour le médecin peut quoi est il a été
champion du monde juniors assez facile
il a fait un sport de fou et et puis
ouais mais là il a quasiment 2007 déjà
quoi oui et il est 3080 surface comme ce
qu'il veut même dire un joueur c'est
quand même le classement de là où ça se
joue et il a quand même 300 points elo
de plus face est énorme fête détails
pour nous mais double tour
ça me fait penser à la phrase de vlad
toi t'es nul moi je suis pas mort fille
extraordinaire cette phrase mais toi tu
es nul moi je suis pas mort fi des
tâches que j'adore la phrase non non en
fait il faisait face à propos de lui
passer quand on court des soucaze
paraphé genre fâche pas gary shaw et
s'est mis à attaquer où il envoyait des
trucs et ils y vont en fait là ce qui
est en train de lui dire c'est toi t'es
nul moi je suis folle mort fisc
si j'ai alors fait deux heures salle
quelqu'un ya tant de tas de chasse qui
n'anticipe admirer les acteurs ont déjà
ou pas bah oui oui oui oui complètement
du classement
je ne sais pas attendez qu'on écrit jack
110 m2 au magot de luz ou peut-être
magh2 aux as mais je n'arrive jamais à
savoir à mais ne me demande pas que mon
exemple de moossou chess je ne trouve
forcément puisque les séries nîmes zola
fab bois propre
alors là vous dire son classement elo je
crois qu'ils les 26 81 65
mais bon 65 s'il a perdu un petit peu
mais bon oui donc il a 19 ans dont huit
filles ont déjà plus jeunes mais pour
l'instant pas plus fort non mais tu vois
un match vire ou jamal ou enfin par âme
ouais ouais un match que banon mais ce
sera un beau match en fait c'est surtout
qu'apparemment plus il a été champion de
dire on dit les gens pioneer en 2017
2018 comme ça enfin le mec il est quand
même là enfin agir pour le moment
palmarès de fil rouge à juin d'espoir je
suis un espoir femme avoue palmarès de
ma vie où je suis un espoir aussi mais
j'ai des titres mais j'ai et il serait
donc non non non par am c'est beau
joueur mais même contre sarah n'a à mon
avis il est plus fort que sarah n'a en
réalité par une ou contrôler jusqu'à la
fin juste une personne qui a écrit une
fois dans un chat une personne très
sérieuse en plus pas apparemment mais
quelqu'un dans un chat où il sera la dre
directement être qualifié pour le leur
affiche un adulte parce que dans le
truck jeunes enfin c'est sûr qu'il va
gagner bon c'est très très sur quoi il
est déjà pas favoris au deuxième tour
mais ah bon c'est sûr qu'il va gagner
quoi fait très attention
donc du coup avec favori gaulle un petit
peu avec ça et dès qu'on voit ça rana un
haut niveau va enfin nous laisse mes
chances ba est ce que c'est quelque
chose de jeu la partie face aujourd'hui
tu dire même pas quoi c'est
extraordinaire grève parce que ça arrive
à roland garros nadal federer est tout
et tu dis oui mon fils doit-il vraiment
jouer ce tour
qui va gagner montagne en a gagné 12 mai
mais bon et la dégager beaucoup plus
fort que toi
il a fait un très beau coup aujourd'hui
mon fils dans les compils a perdu quand
même pas moi [ __ ] je sais pas je peux
que elle a perdu il jouer contre
contraire web et un autre vers berck
saison sur gazon à leur plus fort mais
c'est cc3r parce que c'est vraiment de
ce niveau là en fait le truc de sarah
n'a pas géré là on prend la peine en
fait non c'est complètement nul tu n'es
pas favorite du trafic mais tu dois être
dans le meilleur sur sa honda qui les
prêtent ils n'ont pas invité au tournoi
mag nous disons c'est à dire car aiea
qui n'est pokhran nick setta mans et qui
accueillirent sahara n'a non ça va tuer
le suspense de ce programme beaucoup
trop peur qu il va l'écraser
l'armageddon a par contre les doubles
afin pourquoi de voix file droit de lui
non j'ai fait des déclarations après
après sa victoire en championnat du
monde rapide ne joue pas bon pour la
peine
cette position de femme moi j'aime bien
les noirs perso moi je me dis à tout le
monde en fait je me dis que les
cavaliers dans une position enfin le
truc c'est qu'on regarde ton foot on
food on fout g2 oui mais de revenir vers
détroit peut-être un jour ta tombe
verges et quatre touchés g4 peut-être
terje tout de suite je dis bon coup mais
j'ai quatre peut-être g5 tu laisses pas
de terrain ouais je suis pas de terre
mais peut-être après kg 6 k et h 4
meretz et 6 ou pas pas sûr tu vas devoir
attaquer les vieux travesti ses
compagnons jours mais bon c'est 6
pourquoi pas bon alors je pense ça mange
pas de pain mais je ferais bien phu et 5
en fait où ces six puits fautifs à cinq
n'a pas peur de gk du coup bah tu veux
vers l'abstrait tout le 20 mai voguer v6
normal ce sont sept voix 6 pouces et 4
way
du coup tours en plus ou moins forcé est
fou c'est 4 mais bon
ça sent du niveau comme mesure way pas
d'infos de lâcher pour l'instant bon
alors est ce que l'on peut faire après
du dan 17 échanger les tours échangent
et les tours et faire une petit nul
enfin pour apprendre du fou mais t'as
pas très envie tu veux garder sa colonne
donc vous faire à 3 ou stabilisant
peut-être à quatre ou à 4 mais bon
accueil tout explose à delson des fois
l'ethiopie teneur de la structure des
sept tours 8 et liquides et noir
d'autonomes 17 ira vers 1 4 un moment
ils essaient de s'infiltrer et bond à
madame 17 jouer cavalier 4 faut être fin
- changer ses magazines leurs droits
savas égaliser à fond ouais bah quoi tu
peux jouer sur mon coup de gueule mais
oui les bleus encore caïds et 3 et puis
on est ce qu'on échange avec les les
tours avec les noirs pour tout reprendre
un tour prend un tour tours 8
ouf je fais des rêves c'est un prix et
l'empêchent cahier des trois peut-être
favorite pour toi je crois possible
il va faire la maj cette non enfin il a
pas trop le choix non pas des masses et
maintenant et que les blanches boeuf ou
3f deux petits coups il y aurait deux
têtes g5
ouais on repart en jeu deux amoureux de
woods aurait peut-être tu peux faire ça
à fab four est on est loin d'être obligé
mais je sais pas je trouve ça idiot ce
qu'on peut jouer ailleurs on nous
propose fois fr dans le tchat
ouais pourquoi pas on se devra se
faisait quatre à temps mais on est un
problème avec mon chat
non il ya sam qui est écrit on avait un
problème avec avec le feeder tmp attend
hélix et back musique lauriers c'est pas
la même que celle et petites images en
dessous des caméras fait voyager j'avais
plus le truc
merci sam gerber 5 ok pas mal hein
prise en passant il prendre ces faucons
ses quatre tours s'est vite joli bon bah
du coup pas de mars de fouet c'était pas
grandiose foot est roi
alors du coup là tu penses qui va faire
quoi il va prendre dans le détroit
g6 frégé 6 l'autre bada match 8 g point
fr mais prendre des trois ça te bats non
j'ai juste eu à manoka l'hiver fait
kiffer ce que tu dis est du coup sûr
vous prend ces cas tu prends de btan
pages qui a été trois ouais bon bah là
il n'est pas mal moins on n'y voyait pas
moins de faits racistes vaisseau
consolidé je pense ni d'humanité où
l'erreur des noirs tu penses bapt est
d'amener la dame en h7t peut-être pas si
thibault je sais pas là tu peux
peut-être faire à bab tu prends quand
même ces quatre tu fais b5
mais bon tu attendais le temps peut-être
fou ces deux ou de trois excellents ma
place et wakfu ces deux j'aime bien au
foot pour faire qui est des trois quand
même qu'elle est noire il faut que tu as
tenté d'amener sept cavaliers ou six
nous autres mais bon c'est pas le temps
de me jeter en eau 5
c'est quand même pas mal est-ce qu'on
peut essayer de le dribbler genre tout
reprend à 19h52 région jouit tavéa à bab
et tour à cet e3 ouais ça paye tout elle
a fait pousser 2 ouais bon fois sa
logique libyen la caisse des trois mais
l'autre c'est plus concret que le ventre
tu proposes un festival non mais c'est
peut-être peut-être pour rien mais a du
coup vous la fenêtre au canada mais
cette cavale ie6 non je pense que t'en
penses ouais ouais voilà d'un match soit
je n'ai plus trop vin surtout la flore
et active serait génial de faire barrage
suite tu l'a caché quoi que tu fais roi
g7 après ces six bouts baquet id3 cruise
2 6 6 1 par infosource hollande ce que
maintenant du courrier cavaliers 5
salvat camion puis faut être quatre ou
des six aussi tu peux me planter
mais voilà c'est ce qui va se passer non
non il est beaucoup mieux
mais j'entends ça je suis pas convaincu
fab 4g comprends mais les leaders des
quatre décennies au sort non mais j'ai
l'impression que ça tu vois il
il dessert un peu l'étreinte la petite
hache ou peut-être des 4 way peut-être
profil et puis on mais bon acheter un
qui donne rien bon il ya quatre ans je
pense qu'il faut faire et parce que tout
à l'heure j'ai écouté vlad
du coup un petit peu dans les 18 que
j'écoutais et qu'à un moment donné vous
l'a dit la digue dans la proche moder
maintenant les gens prenez les pions
quand on leur a donné
oui c'est vrai dit maintenant tu prends
c'est plus c'est plus comme avant où tu
avais peur et tout coiffe
bah tu as peur je sais pas je savais que
les gars se matérialisent c'est
peut-être la preuve je leur dis mais des
fois tu redonnes du jeu en reprenant un
tube we had patron vivre mais maintenant
c'est qu'on a un peu on est devenu un
peu matériellement du coup il a fait h
quatre rangées de tête damage 500 d'un
champ que j'ai quatre tours des jours
contre le noir mais un mail au pire que
ce que c'était ça peut se retourner les
longs plus de temps hayange et blanc
sont les blancs son surnom méchant ce
que te faire ag as.g torah suite ah
ouais mais bon il veut éviter de se
faire attaquer un buzz autour nostrum
c'est pas en mode concurrents la magie
c'est bien joué dans risc google is well
as il l'est il est en train de craquer
non pas il a été foutu de plus ont
dépassé les chiens doit plus de temps la
cour nul 2-2 à peut-être prendre du tour
2 échecs des quatre fous lyon aulas le
roi sur la première la fab venir il va
doubler soyons tous les deux tours
euh je pense qu il prend du foot le bon
dos tracé serait bien vrai mais
peut-être s'y prendre il ya tour des
quatre réfléchi peut-être à tour des
deux intermédiaires champion français si
ses tours 2 qui sait petit calcul un peu
ce que la tour des quatre peut-être par
la tour b donnant tout bêtement eu ces
mots le printemps arabe
ouais c'est pour mon dieu et tu vois
moroni moroni très fort après un mémo
ronnie très fort contre contre des
joueurs moins forts n'en veut dire genre
moi par exemple
bon là il est très fort là il me bat
mais mai contre contre eux par à mme
savard d'être un peu léger ce que tu vas
pas rami lille défend quand même bien et
tu as vu quand ils te reconnais ça avec
avec damas 7,3 g 7 h sur un cash 4 pour
sauver ceux d'hommes qui était à
l'agonie mais j'ai pas aimé cailleux
59,4 constat très bien tu gardais tout
en contrôle c'était beaucoup
alors là tout de suite senti 1,5
non mais ça fait mal ayant demandé au
chat d'une petite réaction sur
l'histoire du stade toulousain
dames 1 belle victoire wells était plus
fort n'hésitez plus fort hills est plus
fort mais bon on aimerait bien que ça se
concrétise un peu on coupe d'europe et
aux six nations et tout ça parce que
j'ai l'impression que enfin on est très
fort entre nous non mais tu y as tu
viens c'est quand on est très contents
très gros match et tout bon c'est vrai
mais palmarès quand on vous le leinster
on joue le saracens quand on joue
l'équipe d'irlande l'équipe d'angleterre
alors on est quand même très très fort
mais si tu veux dire son goût du monde a
très mal très mal aussi mais en fait
c'est un truc que je comprends pas tu as
un peu regardé l'écoutent les coaches et
les bookmakers de notre premier match
contre l'argentine
je n'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi on
est favoris parce qu'en gros sur les
plus bas taux alors je m'en bat
largement enfin si tu si tu regardes un
peu en fait l'équipe d'argentine s'est
quasiment joueurs pour joueurs les
jaguars qui jouent en super 15 dans le
sud et les jaguars dans le sud en super
viens de finir deuxième de la saison
régulière derrière les crusaders qui est
en gros l'équipe des all blacks
donc en gros c'est à dire que nous
français dont qui ne gagnons rien qui
nous ont écrasées de partout nous sommes
favoris contre des pumas jaguar voiture
à ses fins j'ai envie de te dire
maintenant tellement je les fabrique
bah on a la france quoi oui bah on voit
cela on va se faire démonter
l'un peut soit se prendre des cuillères
pas argent enfin une cuillère ils ont le
jeu au pied ils font des passes après
contact ils sont beaucoup plus forts que
nous fasse je comprends pas en fait ils
sont vraiment plus fort que nous
cherchons à 6 genre on est à 2 52 60
j'irai bon c'est à peu près ça c'est
quand même la france un fou tu en as
kaka une bonne image surtout pas très
bien mais là on est carrément favori
condé mais qui à mon avis peuvent la
gagne face tu confonds pas mais je pense
que pense brisage qui arrive qui regarde
un peu de rugby mais je vais faire un
show comprend pas en fait je comprends
vraiment pas ce truc là donc soit je
comprends plus rien au rugby femme est
en fait c'est fini tous les bookmakers
soit c'est les bookmakers et enfin soit
c'est moi qui comprend et personne ne
comprend ce soit c'est inverse
car avant il faut viser ce faut miser
sur la défaite de la france mais oui
enfin il sera géré on perd quand même
tout ça on perd contre tout le monde
tout le temps enfin on a même perdu les
fidji quand même fin marie-george bout
d'un moment fait face à ses démons et
des losers fin c'est hélas on sait enfin
belle finale de toulouse mais tu vois ce
que je veux dire qu'il faut faut aussi
remettre un peu la meilleure cote savons
un peu remettre dans le dans le contexte
croit pas ou peu importe fab donc dans
cette partie c'est un genre de benoni
inversée l'exacte e mans où les noms ont
pu reprendre du point e du croupion
c'est donc ce calme un peu les ardeurs
quand même c'est à moins de pression sur
la colonne et a pas de majorité le lob
j'ai l'impression fable que paramétrer
tranquille dans ce match a pour
l'instant même quand il est pas trop
bien la partie d'avant il a pas suivre
ben j'ai l'impression que non mais même
dans son approche du match tu as
première partie dont l'ouverture il
prend une minute et quelques machin
deuxième partie n'a pas été flamboyant
celle là non plus enfin j'ai
l'impression qu'il est venu en mode je
suis plus fort que toi
ouais
pas un instant ces barrages c'est
pourquoi il fait pas que les pros ya
peut-être un problème mais je vois pas
en 85 secondes rouge du coup quand même
et on fait quoi avec les bandes am des
deux tours 1-1 et g3 en fait des actifs
d'amd dont c'était du dom mais si ça
c'est pas si simple
bah je suis pas convaincu de la position
blanche veut dire enfin je suis sûr
qu'elles n'en sont pas mieux après
jean-louis qui m'a jamais jamais trop
joué cette benoni cantat le fongecif
côté blanc bal avec les blancs j'aime
pas trop près du futur mettre le foin f1
mais oui je suis d'accord avec toi y'a
un truc qui fait les blancs peuvent pas
être mieux dedans un point d'eau mais
bon on surmonte échanges vont essayer de
faire faire une spéciale sept nouveaux
besoins égal mais alors un peu près
c'est plutôt une tête un jour tu as un
cavalli clients eux cinq équipes 1 c'est
pas quoi mais bon tant qu avocat les
trois trouvé changé
normalement il va pas se passer grand
chose bref c'est un peu insipide quoi
c'est un peu insipide pour le mans vois
pas de grosse envolée dans ce match la
deuxième partie finalement était la plus
intéressante pour le moment la première
était à sens unique celle là à peu près
égal mais bon il peut se passer des
choses là pour l'instant route
est ce que tu penses qu'il peut tenter
hkd g5
ouais mais quand bien même tu vas te
fera jaser bon pas de s'enfermer la dame
mais je n'étais changer les tours au
passage sur par la bande des huit ou
quoi et je suis pas sûr qu'il se passait
quelque chose de grave mais pourquoi pas
tu veux créer du jeu ça peut passer par
là mais je pense qu'il a pas un gros
risque à lille a déjà deux poneys ans
beaucoup d'autres élus inquiets ces deux
ci de faire b 4 un jour tu as eu un qui
peut vouloir rec f4 et f5 pour essayer
de ce we were il faut prendre ces si ça
peut être une option aussi père francis
dame prend 1,5 et peut-être une menace
ifab que tu couvres tout tu couvres la
case 2 tu couvres la case 1 du cous à
capter la case d3 pardon
bien du dnc s'attelant fait pour
défendre mais il fera peut-être 4 way ou
jour ans assiste quand même endroit pour
faire b prend mais tant pis mon premier
prend s'utilise parce qu'en fait la dame
en b sides je l'avais bien avec les
normes jetons pas de leurs ouais mais
non l attaque b3 et l'empêchent p4 bon à
le faire et d'autres où c'est déjà
suffisant il a immobilisé la dame
adverse la défense aussi donc
ah ok f5 nous très concret fc voilà déjà
rien que vous pensez si ces cavaliers g2
pour aller et visé la caserne
4 et pourquoi pas les preuves
et puis plein d'autres clients ou 4 et
sinon on a toujours notre foot français
6b prendra me prends à 5 peut être à
l'ordre du jour arrive peut-être ferme
f4 tf1 et dames 2e 2 donne des deux
alors à temps double jeu c'est pas mal
aussi mais f5 j'ai fait mes fans
enfin un bouton rouge et 6 mailly il
fait un peu la tronche
enfin c'est un froid youn en cas
d'attaqué des trois permanents tu peux
même à la limite à avoir l'idée de faire
cavalier froid cavaliers h quatre mois
enfin si la prostate mais aussi autre
chose c'est de faire ch et 5 est bloqué
ouais peut-être un truc je sais pas
offrir 3 kg 2 j'ai cinq cd change de
mettre le qualifie castet change peu
fraîche 4 je défends tout et je constate
en dur et on fout
j'aime pas du tout il veut faire d'un
match 4 dans la foulée en fait c'est
juste ok donc c'est très concret puis en
plus l'état malien dit si ça marche pas
mais ça m'a l'air de marcher
ben en fait qu'il a peut-être réussi à
le piéger
peut-être quelque 4 c'est pas judicieux
de la part des blancs on va voir s'il
faut une défense quand même eu ça on
l'avait pas vu non plus n'ont donc après
c'était peut être une erreur tactique
cependant j'ai pas aimé f5 quand même un
nomade joie
qui te félicite dernière vidéo et bravo
le druide pour le montage sur soul gien
fait grand chose de super seulement toi
tu parles je vais 5% de la vidéo l'a
enfin c'est lui qui passe les heures à
monter à faire les effets à mettre les
musiques tu vois moi je ne fais rien en
fait mais ça règle le rendu est bien
j'exploite les gens que j'exploite
complètement trahi
bien sûr bien sûr j'exploite ludwig à
200% donc pas donc ça petit pion qui
sont toujours escarcelle de notre
amoureux nous à moroni kaboul s'il
pouvait convertir si loin d'être faible
damages 4 jouer étonnant quand même ce
début de match je trouve avec un niveau
en dessous doit donc si papa fout ta phu
hiep à foug pa pou première partie quand
même un peu un peu étonnante deuxième
partie finalement avec un gros
retournement de situation et l'a de
nouveau une partie un peu insipide les
noires qui semblent stratégiquement
quand même pas avoir choisi le meilleur
plan mais les blancs qui font une faute
tactique assez rapidement derrière donc
un jeu j'ai envie de dire femme un peu
décousu pour le moment ouais un peu
décousu donc fait froid et ça joue pas
très vite aussi je dois dire non mais
bon ils ont cinq minutes sur excellent
ckoi 5 + 300 +15 cuisse à aucun moment
fait obligés de la police dont nul ne
sait plus on pouvait pas prendre effet
quatre agrafes ou des cinq échecs
découvert la découverte sur la dame qui
aurait fait la découverte sur la dame en
f4 et donc les blancs qui vont devoir se
décider pour quelque chose ici bas y'a
rien de bon jusque là tout jouer vite
espérer un mag et arif est fou et 4
c'est peut-être pas idiot parce que du
coup il se peut se libérer la case d3
pour le cavalier pas mal mais tant pis
je pense qu'ils auraient dû prendre il
prend du fric
donc ailleurs 4 avec 3 ok bon il faut
accepter jouer et peut-être même que tu
as à 4,2 me prendre kelly prend 1,4
c'est bien joué ça à quatre femmes
ouais il va le voir baccarat croire au 5
mai si grave et sur pions prend b3 il a
30 ans dossier celui de tv2 donc il a
fait j'ai cissokho - au sein qui veut se
donner la case f5 pour le cavaliere
j'imagine ok c'est jouer et mais en fait
à 4 j'aime bien quoi qu'il en soit parce
que même b prend à kia soul sera des
bons trucs à faire bon qu'elle soit et
puis tu montres leroy en droiture
hyperliens magie et à l'impasse et au
delà que j'ai un truc qu'on cramer jan
fischer a pas ce moment là je pensais
pas du temps bien consommée quel est cet
autre réflexe il rêve c'est trop 6 c'est
ce qu'on disait ça me semble être assez
simple à gagner cette histoire là pour
pour les noirs fab
oui mais on est quand même le key qui
revient en d3 non mais je pense qu'il a
cumulé deux idées 2 à 4 quevelly à 5 un
peu bloqué là-bas plus le plan hp s'est
quand même passé quelque chose à 4-4 5
ça paraît très fort et bien de forcer
way maintenant il dévie comme ça ok je
sais pas ça peut calculer c'est
évidemment c'est une grosse décision
comme il n'ya peut-être dû à 5
maintenant qu'il faut faire bosser 4 ou
pas nantes avait le temps ok bon là un
truc c'est que
ils ont vu le temps tout peut se passer
peut-être quel point ça qui va faire un
et tu peux si votre apple cavalli comme
ça ils écartelé mais bon ça m'a l'air
d'être gagnant pib 2 3 et 4 qui est d 1
à 4 3 et le rapport à t3 ou quelque
chose comme ça arrive encore une
non non non non il ya plein parce que
leurs ouailles sur blanc et la dame est
sûre noir tout fourchette bombe à bord
d'un break ou deux belles victoires
finalement voit l'or bat sa part l'uaf
théâtre de deux parrains qui n'était pas
idéal puisqu'il s'est pris la double
attaque
mais ok on verra donc savoir spawning
zoo
étonnant quand même à ce niveau là des
erreurs pareilles à peut-être joué un
peu vite je sais pas il n'a pas pris la
peine de calculer l'impôt
il a joué le coup qui semblait bon
stratégiquement combien s'avère très
bien ce qu'ils ont fait est bon avec
c'est un peu ça les échecs c'est un
mélange de de concret et de et de fond
de jeu quoi bah ouais c'est des fois tu
dois tu doit calculer réfléchir au long
terme à la stratégie mais sans oublier
de toujours vérifier en surface qui
n'est pas un problème
c'est ce qui fait la beauté du jeu fable
d'ailleurs bah oui c'est ce mélange des
deux je rends compte qu'en fait
finalement le côté concret avec un
militant important ce qui est normal
quelque part parce que le court terme
est forcément hyper importante je dois
dire si tu meurt sur le champ
qu'est ce que tu vas voir ça beau mais
oui mais je l'épargné mon argent louis
mais bon tu vas tu es mort comme un
moment enfin on s'en fout quoi bon alors
là moroni qui semble encore avoir des
idées belliqueuse ouais très belliqueuse
enfin dans le dos toilé oui mais bon il
va ça lui permet peut-être d'échangés le
fou de cases blanches qui est une arme
maîtresse de l'attak blanche
ouais cependant ce fonds compte ou le
son ou de 20,4
c'est peut-être car il a pris en dessin
je me reprends la trousse avec du coup
tu es vissé en quatre là n'ont pas que
le faire mon enfance mais ce qu'en
jouant quatre maintenant tu peux obtenir
quelque sorte davantage que soient les
noirs vont échanger mettre une tour en
huit
moi j'aime pas je préférerais qu'ils
aient pas de plan de salle pour faire
vos 4 ouais ça m'a paru aussi un peu
étrange fab parce que la prise prise
prise prise sur huit cavaliers à 5 mai
pour venir faire du cavalier c4 j'ai
l'impression que c'est le quart eli qui
domine le fou je pense comme moi le
fouet une vie sur des bleus n'allez
peut-être dé m6 un jour je pense que son
idée voilà eh bien peut-être tour 8am a
peut-être f6 il faut faire un ouais
pourquoi je sais que non mais alors on
tourne autour de 8 d'abord ouais on
pense que jamais m alors soit dam des
trois hommes gilles catoire et life site
je pense je pense pas que tu puisses
tall f6 de la part des blancs atteint
8,7 prendre sept épis dans le clip 6
bien jouer logique et maintenant alors
où mettre le foot ce trophée fois je
suis quand même chaud et fille 4 ou en
fait je me demande est ce qu'on peut
faire quelque chose contre le cavalier
le plan de carélie c4 je crois pas un
nom niveau durant ces quatre ans et 4
donc c'est à dire qu'il faut jouer un
peu au tour donc il semble que le foin
f4 il soit bien placé fois çi ce
pourquoi pas when the logic dont il est
saisi de faits retour aussi s'en suit
donc là ok pourra repartent avec le foin
f4 logique et au plan possible c'est de
naviguer par trois et manger espérer que
tour avec 3
téléphone bon je sais pas si c'est un
autre téléphone vie ou qui fait quoi qui
fait un petit un petit qu'on appelle ça
l'interférence n'interfère en fait des
objets bien silencieux mais je peux
carrément les tendances ou non mais
jussie du l'éloignent peut-être enfin je
sais pas peut-être été proche du micro
et que ça il me faut donc gelé les
histoires fait venir un joint et donc
voila c'était pas très grave c'est juste
pour un pour sauver louis des auditeurs
oui bah là c'était pas très fort en fait
mais je sais que ce genre de choses ça
peut arriver que ce soit fort donc fouet
f4 bon bah maintenant les noirs ils vont
sûrement faire un truc avec les c4 c6 b5
et venir venir jouer sur ce cavalier qui
arrivera en c4 mais c'est vrai que
keynes et 4 il est bien placé mais il va
pas faire grand chose
non mais alors après tu peux t'en servir
bon match nul oui c'est un peu ça tu
peux pousser les pions quoi hassan
bichonne b4 tu aminé c3 et s'il ya plus
étroit quoi c'est l'option des qui sera
faible au coeur c'est 5 direct alors ces
cinq c'est un autre plan typique de
cette structure de piaf à ben oui mais
je vous serai attendu alors un mot qui
est technique mais texture dcb ses fans
en avant tu préfères sur des cirques en
une casse mais alors peut-être qu'il ya
un truc je réalise pas mais bon après de
dieu juste garder cbc et puis ton picard
d'amd 3 est rentrée est allé taper ces
trois quand même c'est quand même assez
étonnant de laisser les blancs sécuriser
la casse et 4 et laisser le carré levier
alors là c'est bien joué et femmes ça
c'est bien joué parce qu'il veut activer
sa tour à 8 pour attaquer sur le pur à 2
et contre attaquer sur le roi et
remettent le cavalier ans et 5 pour leur
place éventuellement vers des trois ou
quatre fa ben ouais c'est pas mal c'est
juste très ambitieux comme blanc est
sûrement cd ça me tentait pas fréquent
avec mais je me demande s'il peut pas
faire plus simple
ah ouais moi ça me paraît vraiment fort
fab honnêtement ça 6
bonfoh 3 d'accord non mais c'est un plan
typique dans sa structure c'est vrai on
voit souvent dans la green faldo quoi
mais qu'il va remettre le pouvoir des 4
je pense et du coup sur coup des quatre
peut-être cavaliers de dvd 6 1 points
ouais ça t'aurait fin pour être bien
placé pour défendre l'option et tu me la
fait bouger en deux ans tu verras tu as
ton curado c'est sur mais bon avec les
montois je suis pas trop inquiet de
perdre
enfin c'est quand même l'impression que
c'est plus simple un jeu pour les noirs
ce histoire le foulée 4 il est bien
quand même c'est un socle c'est dur
d'enlever de la coi après je peux lire
bouge de là comme ceux-là comme sur
l'arrêt jeudi bouger
ouais mais attention une menace enfin
une idée de me faire tour 600w tour soit
un tour propre site si on prend il vous
prend ici ce matin donc fait rire à
stoke
j'ai peut-être parce qu'ils veulent
attaquer limite c'est un peu plus trop
ça non ouais c'est plate mais bon des
fois tu obligé de reculer pour mieux
sauter quoi comme on dit
ouais mais bon c'est un peuple autres
alors alors un truc mon contenu
historique c'est pas mal de l'attaqué
chouchou qui était quand même très
inquiet si c'est bien joué parce que tu
va chasser le fouet mais c'est après je
suis d'accord avec toi du coup et noir
jouent pas pour l'avantagé en réalité
ben non c'est pas toi aussi tu es
vraiment un problème chance puisque ton
froid et si c'était une grosse menace en
réalité et du coup et
du coup quoi faire avec les blancs ouais
je me demande aussi peut-être
non je pense à tourcoing 8 quand même
parce que c'est un point 8 et u ramène
ta dam dam des inquiets ces six d'un
bébé trop un truc comme ça
tourcoing 8 j'aime bien aussi dans le
sens où tu chasses adam de moi j'attaque
watch et plein de choses en face ouais
et puis avec d'amd à 3 refaire du tour
un moteur est bon je sais pas si en b3
b6 mieux placé que ça mais finalement ça
va tu vas à la fois défendre à 200
questionnaires mémoire présenté lors du
tour prend à deux problèmes un bon tant
pis rend le pion il ya sont là ce que
tout roule pour intéressante l'idée
c'est que jordan 17 mois avait fait
profil bas effet tour car il veut quand
il veut toujours way et reprendre une
boisson dégâts peut-être auquel son idée
c'est que surprise en quatre reprises en
quatre
il y aurait eu à tours à huit emprise
hockey ici six tours 1
en fait il veut à ok il ce qui se passe
c'est que si tu prends tout en en 8 sur
adam hier matin
et là sur ces premiers cas tu veux jouer
cavalier prend et surtout reprend tout
reprend pour prendre ces dames prend
d'apprendre et tu l'as vu je montre
juste pour les auditeurs y aurait
d'ailleurs matin mais du coup c'est paul
couet order défendre mais ça va encore
mais pas notifié dames 2 et il s'en
prend à la tour 8 voilà donc la menace
pour contourner gaynor soumaïla tour
sont des changes nous mêmes en 24
j'imagine que celui des tours pour
quatre d'entre eux quatre tours des 8 ou
tour des médias
on va voir comment il continue pour des
mythes direct pourquoi pas un tour ed mi
temps je me suis surtout ravi 8,6
perdrait la tour 8 fab
ouais c'est ça serait moins bien que ce
prix mais en fait c'est vrai qu'il ya
pas des normes n'a peut-être avec les
blancs tu veux un retour c'est ok pour
ces huit très vite sa menace rien non
j'ai pas l'impression vous est ce
qu'avec les blancs on aurait peut-être
intérêt à faire un hymers d'un bref non
mais je sais quand même adresse ferme à
6 4 on souffle est le roi ouais parce
que les matches du couloir c'est gênant
is hot du ku'damm h sac et il menaçait
de tours 8
sur certaines variantes oui oui enfin
faut pas se laisser prendre tôt et avec
les nerfs sont jesse ce matin mais pour
l'instant contient bien ça va je
comprends je conçois reprend les damas à
tous et pour le monde puis en moule
option à deux est tabou parce ya le tour
8 et dames et dames chez sea spa dont tu
parlais plus tôt mais non c'est pas top
c'est un peu tabou doit faire vite si
vous n'en étant pas tabou non plus mais
on va tout jouer vite ma vie d'une
dameuse c'était peut-être une gaffe non
je pense pas et laurent de l'opion mais
ok on va voir sa plus importante à la
tour g8 va pouvoir repartir
peut-être des tanks mais voilà moi tu
prends mes gars tu d'un point dom trombe
et 4,2 me prendrait 5 nature - ne savent
pas se tenir plus ou moins bah oui bon
ça là encore la 6e et pour des 8 et
échangera et hk attention d'échangé
puisque si on est peut-être du tour g5
qui était pénible mais là les noirs vous
quand même la jouer ouais il faut jetons
qu'ils veulent
non mais tu as un rôle à jouer et c'est
normal oui il peut de son hydravion de
plus mais je pense qu'il ne pense pas
qu'il n'y en a déjà oublié c'est nul ils
sont certes mais en plus des panneaux
zoo
tu penserais pas que je jouerais ces
choses là ça c'est complètement nul en
plus
moroni qui réussit à à jouer vite donc
tu vois il récupère du temps petit à
petit s'est bien gardé du temps pour
l'ours serait peut-être utile c'était
décevant pour moi c'est une décision
trop tranquille non mais ça tu
évidemment donné de voir être dans le
rush de toujours était mal entouré de
faire avoir heureusement fils a donné
une tour c'est la vente alors le pire
ajoute en semi tente quelque chose le t
shirt à 3,4 je pense rien ni le fatah
sont tous fous tout et vous il y aura
rien fab
moi j'ai deux attention l échange des
tours mais il a vu il va en 85 je pense
et la paroisse je crois surtout russie
moi je croyais aurais-je et 4 n'est
encore tenir c'était possible ça me
contre les autres plongés sénat bref
trois où il perd très loin ouais attends
attends tu entends ouhlala il part très
très très loin près ouais mais ok tout
est protégé
selon l'iran le roi dans le bouquin oui
tu veux jamais prendre j'ai trois mois
prochain match oh là là au nom au nom
fab au nom au nom comment c'est possible
comment c'est possible fab a annoncé m
[Musique]
photo mc en plus mat et des bas mais
s'il pleut coup la position tu allais
faire radier de leur tour ans puis si le
faisait bien fab mais bien je suis même
jeu tour j'ai 80 ont fichu manger iii et
iv tout entre 11,5 et pas de menace en
fait non tu te suis tu pouvais faire
croire des deux rois détroit où tu
voulais y avait déjà mettront g3 fab
et dommage c'est un petit coup moins que
c'était truqué un point ils allaient
reprendre deux points de retard dans le
match donc 3 mais en plus ce palmarès je
me suis pris de maths en a passé le
deuxième il a déjà fait fou fou d un
tour heures j'ai envie de dire vois-tu
les matins coiffe 1 go acheté mémé 1200
premier exercice d'échec de stéphane
escarres un mégot gogo s'entraîner 1
j'ai même pas et c'est 1200 exercice
suis pas comme il y en a mais je pense
que ça lui ferait du bien de lire ce
bouquin quoi l'armée vont enfin tu
rigoles tu rigoles médias à mai mais bon
il vient de faire bref enfin ex qui
connaît le match retour contre tourcoing
fin contre roy non mais c'est incroyable
fab debout qui était jusque là le temps
c'est la panique s est pas enfin moi je
suis choquée fab moi je suis choqué non
mais en fait tout le chat personnes à
tout le monde a vu direct bah oui bien
sûr enfin je gère le chat est quand même
beaucoup plus fort que sarah n'a pas
faim mais très attention
l'autre ou quatre noms mais c'est la
déception nada dans ce domaine genre
cette partie chat arman villon pensais
pas que j'allais jouer ces choses là non
jean ba les fans pendant trois jours ce
que nous allons faire ok tu pas prendre
le travail fait re 4 3 m il va prendre
la tour je pense mais le problème en
fait si tu as les blancs faire aux
quatre et ont échangé leurs mots est fou
bah oui non mais là il fait le café à
faire pousser un cri des cavaliers
verrou mètres qui va t'attaquer comme
une estonienne mais bon ok j'ai six
peuvent être pour faire quelques
cinquième semaine plus tôt à moroni on
se bat on y croit ou vers les femmes
tant pis tu te fais maths et en un c'est
arrivé deux fois deux fois mais ça
arrive deux fois au mieux ailleurs
on peut tromper mille fois une personne
ouais non de pas tromper mille fois
mille personnes moi je passais l'autre
oui enfin je risque on peut mater mille
fois un coup de balai en fait en fait on
peut ouais 6 à la conclusion
non mais je recommande comment comment
il a pu se rendre ce matin il avait
trouvé là
défense ils avaient tous trouvé roi f1
palmarès fable je sais pas un mois il
m'a fait suer là j'ai plus de tanins
c'est fini fab un beau talent
ouais j'ai sué le tanner partie du golan
c'est un truc tu sais que traite non le
thann ccpt quand tu veux quand tu es des
convictions d'audi building pour pour
pourra être pour être un peu bronzé en
effet bronze en mode eco art and we've
le monde mais un peu trop de monde
ouais ok après quand tu suis trop en
fait le tanit par c'est dégueulasse non
mais là il a plus de thann plus rien
c'est fini je sens que tu utilises ton
que ces deux références d'une vidéo que
t'as pas vu c'est génial mais après
quand tu as plus le thanh s'est finie
quoi c'est le même ses maîtres c'est une
vidéo du maître yoda
c'est le même mec est partout il fait
bûcheron wayne bridge a eu une à colmar
il fait tout genre il entraîne un mec on
a une copine une compétition de
bodybuilding et je peux te dire que
c'est pas peter potet pas tapoter pas il
est nickel
elle entraîne un mec il était
dégueulasse c'est pas de douche et
pendant pendant quinze jours et il a sué
et tout le temps est parti c'est venu
preuve que le tan par baa c'est quand tu
as eu en fait moi donc un bon signe as
tu fais quoi messahel c'est un problème
c'est un problème et donc du coup la
moroni la plus le tan quoi il a tout
tout qu'est parti c'est dégueu ouais
mais peut-être que du coup il a les
bords très lisse
il a pour respirer peut-être ben je suis
pas sûr qu'il faut qu'ils restent bien
moi je trouve l'impression que il va
plus jamais faire de compétition de
bodybuilding là c'est fini
le poète année non mais il est là c'est
sa carrière derrière lui là c'est pas
comme peter poté pâques a quand même été
champion de france
non mais j'aurais été quand même
champions de france quittent au repos
tepa cherche y peut rien je quitte à
reporter pas champion de france il a
fait 5e à l'art notre classique
enfin gériez la cua ne sont pas minces
quoi
et un beau palmarès gère parlement
moroni non mais la duke est là je crois
je trouve c'est bien joué il prépare
chez quatre ans oui mais prépare il
prépare petit à petit puis livrée par f4
aussi d'autres kg 2e ou je ne sais pas
je pense qu'avec g2g 4 f 4g 5
je suis de plus en tête qu'un maniaque
cinq ici mais ça prouve au meilleur que
c'est une case où on peut aller un peu
de partout quoi je sais pas non mais
c'est dur c'est dur parce que parce que
parce que moroni il faut il faut qu'ils
mettent les points il m'a pas l'air
d'être en grande forme param param enfin
magma goût enfin on sait pas comment il
s'appelle en fait mais mais il m'a pas
l'air d'être en grande forme cet homme
dont on ne connaît pas le nom bon il
fait pas il faut un bon match devant il
est là quoi il fait pas trop fait trop
d'erreurs enfin c'est pas trop d'erreurs
enfin palmarès
bah ils volent et maintenant ils
voyaient m'attendre et c'est ça qui te
remets laval quoi ils renvoient la balle
mais il met pas la valeur de couloirs ni
rien il est là mais la wii à ce renvoi
grave la balle c'est dur ouachin kg 5
kgs h3g 2 s'est pas foulé de foot c'est
un
je suis là non je suis là et peut-être
fr g4 il menace là mais à mon avis ce
qu'il veut faire passer le temps et
finir quand on voit dix secondes chacun
qui peut peut-être faire j'ai quatre
franchises g5 c'est pas la fin du monde
doit faire pour préparer f4 sur ce coup
là alors l'autre option c'est un plan
possible
c'est un peu long mais c'est eux
faria les 1 5 kg un f3 par exemple aux
quatre temps auquel je crois que même en
f2 day 1b 2 à 4 vous saviez bien aidé
comptant ce genou des finales ou quoi
parce que tu vises investi sa cave un
peu non astral englouti fait tour 2
qu'elle est inquiets ces deux pays
inquiets non des métros roulaient en p3
non c'est à catherine nouveaux mots qu
après tu réussis faire caïds et 2b 3a tu
vas me eric morain benoît alors que hg
revenait pas lui même que moi mais je me
sentais en criant généreux mais c'est
dur trop un plan en fait ça s'est
débloqué déjà les lames et frises et
petit jeu là bas et puis le roi ben
laden et que tu fais un truc que c'est
quand même aussi une concession quelques
pas ouais non mais il se passe pas
grande mais tu vois c'est pas
honnêtement c'est pas un match non ou
c'est moi qui bat c'est le style de jeu
des joueurs qui donnent sans faute c'est
pas avec ses excès cyr et il a aussi qui
joue beaucoup de pollution comme ça et
je pense son idée c'est de faire courir
le chrono parce qu'il m'a l'air plus
alertes quand il y donc un second choc
mais peut-être aussi il se dit que en
plus sain et en trois plus un air encore
un peu plus une plus grande différence
donc juste et mail à ceux des partis
pour me lancer au 31e où il ya un hub à
y aura rien il y aura peut-être mais il
n'y a rien là c'est sûr il va peut-être
faire j'ai quatre à un moment donné un
nom mais quand autre ordi de monde mais
est ce que dans ces parties là au final
je fais la même erreur que moroni en mai
ce qu'est un moment donné il faut pas
juger jouer vite fait jouer des coups
ouais je suis joues et tu vois il a émis
2 52 contre 50 secondes au moment où on
décide de faire enfin un truc
kate est on prend une fois et ont fait
cavaliers df 6 comprend
production mais qui est des six pourquoi
pas cinq doigts que c'était la finale
oui au tarif 5 mais bon ça lâche la case
aux cinq quand même ma foi pourquoi pas
mais bon faut s'y faire
il y va ce qui est la logique alors
est-ce que tu as le temps de faire
demi-tour 17,5
ça serait idéal pour les nurses il faut
le faire mais c'est pas clair que le
temps passe que par celui de geci ça
aussi c'est peut être un problème la
tenue du pion branger 6 à venir avec
d'am-dam les trois dames g2 les tours
qui débarque et puis là-bas second non
mais va perdre il a plus le temps pour
gérer une telle position s'est
compliquée la baïonnette ferme qu'il
cherchait un ff iii pourra menacer ou
cinq et six sociétés rejettent j'étais
pas très précis bon genre sont réglés
une pièce manquait pas grave
kelly h5 oui bon d'objets cap peut-être
d'objets 4 j'aime bien sinon il ya
peut-être qu'à l'étranger si ce qui est
un coup puis on prend puis on prend sa
force 3 prend et on cherche et tutu
prend 1,5 et bregy sa mère de marché
ouais tu gagnes ou tu regardes le
cavalier h5 enfin deux variantes fait
mal et il fait bien jouer fab
merci tard mais bien vu c'était pas
c'est pas facile vertu même faire au
vieux tours géantes avec a eu cinq
échecs aussi jouable je me suis beaucoup
entraîné un puzzle ruche ce moment-là on
as kg 5 encore c'est fini et à tour g1
aussi qui arrivent il ya tout partout
bon ben j'ai peur que le registre un
massacre c'est ce qui était prévu mais
ça se matérialise quoi y'a peut-être
qu'à l'épreuve e5 c'est avec le pion h6
qui
il reste pas en l'air non dans
l'émission se fait jusqu'à les h4 en
fait tourner la tête et tu vas en outre
ces inquiétudes partout boum
si ce n'est pas reculer le fou d
apprendre et run oui c'est fou prend g7
aussi beau et froid c'est d'autant plus
quand il a envie comment gères
intermédiare assez peut-être maths en
fait ouais bon et laurent abandonné et
ça fait 3 points d'écart ouais mais ça
fait cher parce qu'il est plus fort
paramé moroni qui a raté ok les deux
premières parties qu'il avait perdue il
n'était pas si mal dans la première
attaque est la deuxième c'était un
cadeau dont qu'il a il a vraiment faire
un point voir un point et demi à son
adversaire et maintenant campara miss
mais accéléré parce qu'il va pas dormir
pendant tout le match bassa s'ils payent
cash
ouais ouais bah écoute c'est comme ça
l'humanisme italien fratelli d'italia
tout ça je le redis l'économie
là c'est un peu là d'accord parce qu'on
va mettre limites ou sa petite façon il
va perdre donc on va te lis pas fan des
compatriotes quoi oui mais bon enfin je
préfère se mettre caruana quoi fin tu
vois c'est que tu vois un peu plus
violent quand même parce que là c'est
parce qu'il fait là ça me donne pas une
montagne
enfin je ne mettrai pas l'hymne italien
pour cette performance ça ne m'intéresse
pas nous méritons banon qu enfin la fin
du jeu super coiffe un dommage gagnera
l'hymne italien mais pour le moment tu y
as pas avoir y avoir du cavalier e 4 tu
m'as se rééduquer pour un f2 dame fc bas
ça pour à votre porte j'ai troisième
poste comme le dénomme briquet ou quatre
ça ça me fait très peur en fait de te
faire juger de ces doubles et les pions
vampire 20 mai fu jen je fais carey
price doit peut-être m non alors c'était
proche un bon gars qui est le gaz est
obligé de faire [ __ ] 314 c'est que on
s'est trop d'avocats 13
quelqu'un ça fait peur en fait je
conçois le principe de la peut-être
cavaliers n'ont alors 3 the battle temps
mais il est mal ouais les couilles dans
ce genre de scénario ou cinq points
intéressants si michael caine j'avais
bien bouché parce qu'on aurait bloqué le
temps je regarde l'heure avec l'ordi
quand j'ai des coups qui sont bien je
regarde bon c'était le coup ignorant de
leur dire je vous le savoir il disait
fouet
4 oui je n'hésitais pas perdre mon âme
tu souffres non mais h5 ses parts à
l'oci quoi tu veux faire h4 wii
classique mais la meute en fille enfin
je crois que je le prends dans votre
problème avec les bouffer refuge et de
rock noir entend bien tant pis on voit
ça m'a téléphoné à sa presse traquer la
troisième fois oui bon après façon ce
fait maths et en inde habitude donc
autant sans menottes à long terme bah
oui n'améliore qu'à petit à petit
moroni rentrer dans son match est temps
mes cahiers sur cinq ans veut pas faire
peut-être caraïbes 4 mais j'ai peut-être
pas mal fou g5 wii et sur damien qui
peut faire quoi qu'est froid et caraïbes
4 ouais ce que je regarde farc étrange
je pense est de 3,4 puis changez de la
valve on va passer 80 mais bon on va
savoir va dépenser 4 et puis petit à
petit on va stabiliser
tu as envie de dire petit à petit
l'oiseau fait son nid
voilà calmet mais ça a l'air d'être un
don mais je peux jouer aussi au ni oui
ni ni massage ou fognini winnie ni quoi
faire un jour cf
nous avons à dire mon corps est alors à
dire non mais c'est vrai si je te dis
dans quelle maison vivent les oiseaux
enfin tu vois c'était très piégeur
oh mais tu vois c'est comme ça bon alors
ce qu'on appelle ton un peu les japonais
à quoi les japonais tuent les appeler en
fait d'alger pas leurs hôtes dans le
début du money time et non mais ça
registre et toi ça se serait su tisser
beaucoup plus intéressant que l'autre
ouais ça les gens ne connaissaient pas à
ce jeu alors qu'avait lieu 4 paraissait
le coup candidats ici pour robben à
samatan majeur car il ya eu 4 moroni va
te faire chier prendre 5 c sur steam
quoi m'attendre troisième je serai bon
sinon non mais ce serait beau ah oui
mais non il va prendre même moment et on
en arrête pas je pense vraiment que
c'est pas possible
aussi impossible mais moi je suis dit
que c'est possible
moi je suis qui ont apprécié non moi je
dis non à à pourrain d'imaginer comment
c'est possible jouer quel prof 5
d'ailleurs son ca je quitte le stream ou
siffler quel point c'est son nom est
très piégeur au ni oui ni d'ailleurs ah
oui c'est excellent que le dr tu as tu
remarqué son pseudo c'est morrow il y
joue déjà au jeu il joue au jeu des
génies quoi bon alors mais tu vois mais
je trouve que c'est les parties sont
enfin j'dis pas les parties sont lentes
enfin je comprends pas il n'y a pas de
rythme il manque un truc dans ce match
fab
je suis d'accord nous permet de parler
d'autre chose on est content en fait
faux bond louis dans mais je sais mais
c'est juste pour dire non lors de 9e
coup
il ya déjà ya déjà 6000 de passer dans
la partie ouais je sais aussi c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui va dans ce
match on l'a enlevé l'or du temps que ça
suffit de voir un buzzer et on buzze là
en tant que public et on leur enlève une
minute chacun chaque fois immédiate
immédiat mal dans la bible n'a pourtant
la sauce ait not only coup ça pulse mais
il faut défendre avec deux bonds il n'y
a pas le choix d'appeler les cinq
attaques et f2 en fait et pour eux car
il ya qua non méthode qui regarda me
prend 17 je sais pas mais ça m'a l'air
d'être des bbc à kelly prend qu'il
prenait 5 qui te fais prendre
tu fais tout prendre en fait ça marche
pas mais je qu'on peut comprendre
d'apprendre et cette savoureuse et une
microseconde
enfin pas plus ça non voilà on le
regarde mais eux
mais quoi d'autre en fait quand même
failli et des menaces
à moins que dame détroit son époux
candidat je sais pas j'ai dit soit
complètement fou et qui bâille a pris
voilà non mais quand même deux minutes
de réflexion mais c'est incroyable c'est
le couple tu dois faire tempo genre est
ok je peux comprendre qu'il ait calculé
la suite 0i c4 attaqué je vais défendre
mais pierre déjà tu joues le coup obligé
et dans des calculs plus fera après
toute façon dans un courtier à me voir
en moins de six toiles - de fond de la
tête mais je fais plus facile juste
turpault son cerveau je comprends pas
trop là il ya peut-être y avoir un truc
avec tours serre qui peuvent être arrivé
non mais j'ai juste l'impression que ça
joue mal non mais vraiment pour son
argent fou des quatre chèques aubry non
mais ça va venir
il ya fait refouler quatre fous des deux
bouts vous fait avec le roi et il y en a
peut-être à rien qu'on est pas aux
menaces de maths en à un moment donné
l'émeute et matin elle et il réfléchit
c'est génial m'a fait réfléchir à quoi
je vais bouger bouger quatre
intermédiaires c'est quoi le projet
peut-être rouge et quatre intermédiaires
mais on prend ces cinq quand même oui
bon tu peux peut-être faire contre
intermédiaire encore caïds et cette
hausse permet d'intervenir et c'est un
match qui est installé dans un faux
rythme ouais mais c'est ça votre france
essonne qui est 17
mais bon j'ai un vase le truc c'est que
il se laisse attraper les deux dans le
respect de l'autre qui jouer vite en
fait ça va quand même pas mal mais là
non tout le monde est lent mais un peu
plus bas en fait j'ai l'impression que
c'est un rythme qui arrange parham frais
qui glisse est d'une lenteur c'est vrai
c'est très étrange que c'est du blitz
mais il ya vraiment fort hills et c'est
comme dans les matchs de foot des fois
tu t'installes dans un faux-rythme
pouvait hameau tennis sans centraux que
ça s'explique en fait ça se passe comme
ça dans le jeu c'est un coup de génie
qui met 50 ans tu me dire non mais la
faute il joue un peu plus vite quand
même il reste 20 secondes
je comprends parfaitement joué le coup
non mais il te reste jean un sauvage et
trois avec deux choses m'ont des quatre
vingts métier il rejette 2 3 secondes
par coup alors qu'il reste 20 secondes
c'est incroyable il risque de perdre à
cause du temps pas même si la position
est très égale bas et va faire tour c8
qui est des deux ne tient il reprend 3,4
secondes et il change tout
malause enlevé le bas refusent bah oui
tu dois pas faire nul avec les noirs
quant à une nuit de plus ici quand même
on arrive à accepter c'est sur fable
salon s'ils acceptent ces quarante
secondes qui réfléchit ah non non mais
il doit pas il doit jamais oui tu veux
qu'ils m'entendent elle regarde la
lenteur les fous aussi ce qui est des
trois ans j'ai envie de dire il pleut
dans mon coeur comme il peut sur l'âge
et 1 kg 5 h 4g pas d'en deviner les
coups comme j'ai 5 h 4 c'est un problème
d'autres pages et 5 et du coup de
torchon faut aussi ce nom mais quelle
est cette langueur qui ralentit m'a
souri j'ai envie de dire j'ai 5 allée f
mais je sens qu'il ya un carton 4-0
oui on m'a pas tant pis enfin je sais
pas mais je veux jouer un coup riche et
matthias bieber
non mais tu avais une nuit d'avant ce tu
vas être moins bien autant on ne feint
pas de marest a fait que des coups de
merde quoi enfin j'exagère mais enfin tu
as rien fait de spécial en fait je
comprends rien pilote nous venons 10
secondes chacun en fait ouais c'est un
match très étrange très étrange
tyson gay oui mais non mais il va tomber
avec les noirs non mais c'est
extraordinaire c'est lui qui a malmené
autant
mais si sony n'ont jamais vu sa femme
ont le droit
c'est juste je sais même pas quoi dire
par messieurs je suis en train à bussy
devant mon écran et de me dire mais
qu'est ce que c'est quoi mais qui sait
ces types qui sait c'est type cdo me la
mets toi t'es pas en train de lui signer
la ce rapport pointe du temps en marché
de ce four ou quatre matches en 16 non
et c'est mx37 bien joué il a vingt
quatre heures caillaud devenant way 4,8
ses potes qui est que son contrat
ah oui j'ai pris la mamba de le bullet
je crois que c'est un carnage quand je
vois ça non mais attends balancer trois
campings
oui oui mais enfin c'est joliment
l'écaillage cette 6e manche du truc
allez mange mange mange les ramène ton
cheval oui mais attend il n'a pas le
temps de prendre g4 non pas tant pis
pour tous ces jeunes je donne des
conseils mais il va perdre
ah oui mais bon moyen a pris des pions
peu marre mais bon tu donnes des
conseils il va prendre les pions farouk
et palmarès itunes qui arrivera il a
encore perdu là le problème c'est que
toute façon je crois qu'il ne pouvait
rien faire d'autre c'était perdu quoi
qu'il arrive une petite française à
comprendre ça vous voyez vous nous
remettre le faux-rythme coiffard man to
b 5 mois les méfaits du coup j'ai quatre
dames bougez rock entre lutte dans la
mare hier à mes fans je comprends pas ce
match en fait je comprends pas je suis
en sueur comment les toucher 4 on va
demander cette ligue roc
mais tu vois je comprends pourquoi ces
derniers temps bunga bunga
j'ai l'impression que c'est là le petit
box quoi le norwich est ça pourrit les
échecs en fait mais depuis tout est
pourri peu près depuis depuis ça depuis
depuis depuis le norwich est en fait tu
n'as plus de matchs tu n'as plus de
matches et on vise 9,3 c'est que
vraiment de la merde quand j'ai 5 g
cannibales et là il faut qu'ils la
gagnent allez allez lucas on pousse quoi
epci ce g5 h5 peut-être et g4 à l'ère
blanc via les fameux met tout dedans
allez comme luca toni en demi finale de
la coupe du monde
nakheel 2006 2006 soit je pense et
marqué contre les allemands contre avant
la victoire en finale belge s'est fait
tuer tu pensais pas que j'allais dire
ces choses là tu pensais pas que
j'allais dire ces choses là
dans le chat y pensait pas non plus il
pensait que ce serait tabou tant parce
que de cette défaite
barrett c'est en fait à l'ess mais on a
les lacets il joue vite en plus moroni a
laissé c'est le sait la sela remonte à
la halle et polluent kolélas canal
marron dessin qui me est une punition
bien comme il faut bouger 5 c'est ça
allez une tourangelle huit a pu ranger 4
ayache sa calandre avant toits tours
j'ai vite soit on s'en fout calcule pas
on s'en fout jouer étaient minces
bah oui enfin t italien tu parle avec
les mains tu avec les marins tu vas tu
veuilles ou non mais si tu es un vrai
italien tu vois tu lâches 5 kg cas tu
joue vite
poulsen non mais non mais il faut pas
irréfléchie quoi je ne veux pas
m'asseoir mais oui mais voilà ils riront
dans le faux rythme d'iraniens là faut
arrêter tu envoies tout dans la gueule
quoi ai-je 5 g 4 puis c'est tout
belle pour prendre un bon je sais pas
pourquoi pas aller le mans match 5
maintenant je sais pas à chaque maman
oui bah voilà allez allez
voilà fable et on est bon là allez on a
vingt secondes d'avancé la pendule c'est
déjà ça et on lit on va tous aller ça
c'est pas toi qui le dira c'est
vérifiable
c'est écrit non mais oui il ya de plus
en plus froides à les normands plus
hyper hyper hyper sur ses propres fautes
l'italien fait c'est des cadeaux quoi
s'est il a cru que c'était
il a cru que c'était noël ou la saint
valentin on ne sait pas on sait pas on
sait pas quelle caisse qui croient que
comme fait mal et j 4 non mais québec a
c'est bon ça fond du lac arqués il prend
des saints qui me regarda me croyaient
tous âges 2 donc de bust super quillan
des syndicats tuc bouger car il met
bruit plein week end mais ça moi je
roulais avec avec g4 perso mais qui est
efficace et c'est logiquement pas juste
un étudiant de province
c'est comme s'il a toujours dams et 4
dames e4 bon matin le droit mais tu peux
jouer aux joutes de plus utile au québec
quatre vingts je bats notre côté
peut-être qu'il faille protection
cavaliers peut-être s'ils libèrent
saddam on sait pas mais pour aller où
mais y'a pas tout réussi ça qui est
pénible à ses copains
bon tant pis projet 4 mai mais bon
effectivement c'est que cinq petits
coups de monsieur assez bien joué ça tu
comprends qu on prend et il va ouvrir
son fouet va menacer aussi ça mais ça
s'est super bien joué
ouais ouais mais voilà je vais faire
québécois mais pas toutes ces conneries
quoi
youpi refusé dommage sachant tout comme
ça que tu ai pas vu tu avais des cases
l'aï mal pris l'habitude 1,8 au piano
est inhabitée 6,6 peut-être seconde
question ference et s'excuse bas je
prends je bande armée dans huit attaques
efficaces
ok c'est casey à suez dans deux jours et
puisque c'est ce que je suis ce que je
suis le deuxième coup que je te glisse
comme ça j'ai glissé le petit g4 avant
et là je t'en ai glissé un deuxième en
fait je te lis des petits easter egg
quoi de partout mais peut-être même
camaïeu 4 d'ailleurs sur adam 8 nom
vient de partouzes mais c'est fini en
fait non pourquoi bordel j'ai le droit
oui malgré le quadrillage des quatre
pieds c'est qu'il ya dans le même cas si
si ça se trouve c'est énorme ça ne sert
absolument à mes primes est ce qui rend
ses gardes ailleurs au baby foot
bon je joue ou fausse 4 allée jouer des
coudes tard et des 3b 8,1 mais on me dit
non mais je crois qu'il n'a pas le mais
attention pour venir appuyer les hommes
faisaient cavalier aux quatre aussi
c'est encore pire ce qui vous attend ici
sa vessie ferait pas bon foie est
ouverte à tout ce qui est prôné 5 août
avec les primes 5 et prend des 600 f 5
ça il n'a pas le temps de te faire dans
y'a pas de ventre ça le point de faire
d'un puissant kent wells un peu je
referai thériault on ne va pas faire
annuler la non mais non tu faire complet
cinq dames 8 et peut-être caillou 4 dans
ce sens là bref instant dollar et
inquiet quatre bombes pas qu'il
prendrait 50 mt 6 a vu quelque chose là
quand même d'être potentiellement il ya
des choses neuves en inde et tant pis on
croit qu'il ya une défense week-end des
5 et puis on verra si on n'a plus rien à
perdre mais il faut le faire face bah
oui quoi d'autre sinon ab science est
mort naturellement on peut faire trois
fuites enfin tu peux faire maintenant
bon allez allez femmes
on y croit j'ai un charme fou que ça
tient ben j'ai l'impression aussi j'ai
pas vu le problème
les italiens c'est bien mieux pouvoir ne
pas le prendre suis là mais bon c'est
vrai mais damas a tué lors d'un match 7
j'aimerais bien quand c'est pas ça ça me
plaît moins que j'avais plus pu isoler
le four b2 il est moins débile rodéo si
à un moment donné je te dirais le roi ou
g4g 4 toujours ok bout voilà j'ai un
objet de cautionner quoi peut-être sait
si cela est pénible non production tente
on a fait g41 germain on a fait une
victoire morale non c'est parfait non
mais faut vraiment qu'ils la gagnent 1
pour tuer un match
pat je pense même si la gagne a pas de
match mais j'ai aussi la perle à ces
catastrophes le baril et pleutre il
donne un pion peut-être faut le prendre
le prochain modern the shock très
moderne
bah voilà le bonheur 10 l'italien cdu
leonardo davinci ça fait très attention
when she code bombe à te faire ces six
jours ont une offre française si c'est
moins que si je sais qu'il avait une
chanson de jean luc dehaene de m6 aulas
qui s'appelait davinci claude oui oui je
sais ce qu'ils appellent claude kouassi
davinci cloud j'adore les jeux de
nouveaux missiles débile que sa voiture
j'ai vite tant pis tant j'aime bien ça
fait froid m6 peut-être crois qe 3 un
peu plus tard je suis je pensais très
bien à mes tours g8
j'aime bien changer vite à mon tournoi 8
on est moins bien ça va quand même ok
peut-être sur food prices il veut quand
même car et des f3 ouais ouais j'y crois
pas trop en fait lebon qui ça by many 4
3 ben on y croit on veut y croire faut y
aller maintenant fabing à laymont fab
ainsi généré ce que c'est moi qui jouais
quoi faire un fou pas ce trio majeur tu
participes à respecter ce serait génial
de voir tes parties non je peux le
speech et juniors que non mais qu un
torrent j'évite lancera subir aux autres
élèves 3 bah oui et 7 ou 8 oui et si tu
peux quand même faire
ouais je sais pas ce qu'on va devoir ce
qui est d'alger si ce qui va arriver et
je vois ouais mais c'est plutôt épais de
voir quels outils il va prendre presque
obligé non il est triple boucle ascan
pelote ne pas prendre une arme et tu
dois prendre quand même déjà je vois pas
ce qui se passe exactement si on prend
mais sinon même cas et des six l'autre
ce n'est non pas de 59 ce qui est des
six à forcions prend des six ouais je te
refais puis on prend après je te prends
des cinq puis voilà j'arrivais mechri
kane 4 je suis pas mal à me moquer mais
tu dois prendre quand même son projet de
lancer cavalia 4 1 ou d'un merci dame
s'est grandement qu'il a appris au fait
ya même pas d'idée en fait c'est génial
il joue pas wes helms a fait il a juste
à leiria tracés seront stoppés ouais
ouais mais bon
panayotis aspire le roi truc à domicile
oui mesdames est d'ailleurs la preuve qu
adam et fils d'ahmed 5
non mais on croit que dans le froid pour
angers 5 jeux sebhaoui après que sais-je
tour j'ai vite puis on verra pour entrer
là dedans on est obligé de le minorer sa
est intéressant ou tu fais jamais eu de
jeu par de justes 3,4 peut-être govinden
trouve pas et tout reprendre en dix-sept
ouais mais bon
la finale peut-être allez ça va pour les
noirs non mais il faut jouer plus vite
là surtout véhicules première sem 3 h 4
ici aussi parce qu'en fait tu avais vu
d'am-dam 6 rouges et 5 ou un truc comme
ça j'ai 3 et froid t'as pas d'échec mais
j'ai 3 3 et 2 ouais tu m'as sera ok
peut-être faire ah oui j'ai 3 vous faire
ok ça va aller alors health 3g 2 j'avais
pas vu c'est génial en fait on est déçus
ce qu'on veut qu'il va arriver mais bon
ça peut prendre aisément à mutek ton at
on fini à 17 h un mois c'est une
position de folie il ya 17 à la fin mais
là il ya tour des huit matchs oyama tu
n'y a pas d'accord ouais mais il va y
avoir échec échec et non il ya eu 2 qui
ton nom mais très mal find the monde il
ya pas trop de menaces de damages 2
d'alger tran huy d'alger 3 s'est pas
fait attendre mais il ya des reproches
59 à terre c'est pas clair ce n'est pas
ce qu'on bloque les caisses blanche
normalement il y est quand même bonne
chance de sauvetage moment mais c'était
chaud quoi n'y avait pas de ma main et
kelly si vous aussi vous pouvez pas
faire mieux que 5e mais dommage c'était
une super position mon levier plus temps
mais bizarrement il arrête m jeu des
bons cool quand tu es plus le temps mais
il va la tenir la fois la tenir ayvaz iv
c'est le mans plus la deuxième bonne
nouvelle c'est que c'est un mauvais
point on n'a pas le goût pour la couleur
notamment évidemment s'ils s'y opposent
ça fait chier des trucs
quels outils tant que le plan maintenant
c'est bien vrai ça ira au 4 août peut se
faire du guip ouais mais le problème
c'est en plus heureusement que tu la
crise
il n'aurait pas joué si s'échauffent
avant mais c'est fini non comme une
crêpe
on apprend ainsi c'est bon ça pousse
partout est roi et en relief plat karaté
il ya d'autres gens passer c'est trop il
ya plus besoin ce gastronome c'est
horrible mais dès qu'il ya plutôt là le
franchement le but let's get raquette à
temps n'a pas un père pète à nauroy ces
quatre paquets vides à la serim ya f5
qui part c'est fini aïe ça fait mal fait
mal ça l'a pas parce que je suis sûr
qu'il a laissé passer une occasion mais
il fallait vite en bas toujours mais
ouais ouais mais ça fait 6 1 par mais
c'est cher mais bon votre se bat c'est
la différence de niveau enfin je pense
qu'en logique en réalité monsieur besson
avait prévenu avant le match où tu
aurais pas de match ce qu'on prévoyait
d'ailleurs on a prévu on a prévu avant
le match serait pas de match comme une
grosse expertise ici quoi ah bah on vous
avait dit le norwich est ce que ce
serait complètement de la merde ça a été
le cas là on a dit qu'il ait pas de
matches a pas eu de match aller on se
trompe rarement
alors qu'est ce qu'on prévoit d'autre
part grandes gestions ça être aussi
nulle part pour le sert à rien [ __ ]
dans l'histoire son médecin et grand
prix ça est bien grand mot sonne bien
ouais non mais vraiment on a aussi pris
oui mais en même temps toute façon
toute façon c'est forcément intéressant
parce que c'est un des rares truc à
enjeu avec vous rappelle ce qu'on
appelle de l'enjeu c'est en fait le
titre mondial
le cycle du titre mondial pour être
président donc
donc en fait mais sur le match de
championnat du monde après tout les
qualifs qui en découlent avant donc le
tour des candidats
évidemment dans un an mais avant ça les
qualifs pour les candidats et donc y est
les grands prix il ya la coupe du monde
il y a il y aura le courage of man
aillent tous les autres tournois ouais
ça va être fait un peu le grand chef
tour rapide
ouais parce que ça fait des parties
rapides on est content mais en fait
globalement certaines règles oui mais
c'est un genre de on va dire de
championnat deux parties rapides semi
amical honorifique manière c'est un peu
la même truc que le portugal a gagné la
cua ouais la liga et la ligue des
nations je peux un jour de liquidation
bon c'est même pas très efficace ifa
l'euro ce qualificatif à rien mais bon
tu es contente un trophée c'est ça c'est
à peu près ça le grand classe tour cette
année mais bon il ya quand même quelque
chose que là par exemple norwich est ce
qu'on utilisait la coupe des
confédérations se trouvait était gentil
au final parce que je pensais même pas
des confédérations qui est bon c'est le
tournoi hassan ii ouais c'est ça ça soit
en fait tu fais tu sais tu viens juste
prendre ton chaque quoi ben là c'est
vraiment cette impression mais toute
façon pour régler ce problème fabia pas
dix mille manières fort va être clair
soit il faut que tous les tournois et un
rapport avec la qualification candidat
donc il ya un genre d'affiliation qui te
fasse un grand circuit ce qui m'a aussi
plaint d'ailleurs tu pues pas tous ces
tournois comme un affilié avec des
points des points qui sont donnés à la
fin de chacun des tournois
donc ça c'est une première possibilité
là du coup tu donnes de l'enjeu à tous
donc c'est possible
deuxième possibilité tu crées un
classement comme un classement atp et
tête enlève le match championnat du
monde entre guillemets et tu fais un
classement l'année
qui c'est écolo serait moi ou en
caoutchouc quoi ils viennent y
repartirait rien voilà là où tu fais du
cno calmes mais bon même là ce serait
quand même sans enjeu si tu craques out
même le nord où est chez ce même manque
tant qu'outsider l'intérieur non mais
bon au moins sur un terrain politique
un petit intérêt pour le pilote lutte eu
des matches à élimination j'avance époux
le prince oui mais bon plus cool ça
reste quand même moyen moyen mais qui
fit peut-être se redéploie 0,6 pour
taper des quatre ça c'est un peu la
partie qu'ils avaient déjà joué ou la
dame eutelsat la baule à la deuxième
partie du match
alors j'ai une bonne nouvelle fab 1
parham a perdu la connexion 1 donc ça
peut équilibrer le match parce que ça
peut aller vite c'est aimer jacques
labia 6-1 6-2 dans trois minutes
quarante trois dans huit minutes mais
une pause vous arrêtez la pause là mais
bon s'il a pas de connexion d'ici une
demi-heure il va il va commencer à
prendre beaucoup de bulles mais surtout
vu d'autres ouais même en trois minutes
tu vois si c'est la patte mission
pendant pendant 27 minutes ça lui fait 9
9 0 quand même ma main si la retrouve la
connexion bravo dream by mais bon moi je
pensais que c'était peut-être les états
unis qui commençait l'embargo sur l'iran
quant au couple internet
mais sur internet donc il et quels pays
par amy l'iranien manqué fuite ya eu six
classiques mais il joue bien par à main
enfin alain jeu des portes entre autres
sous un titre très bien je pense je
pense que le problème du match en fait
pour dire de ce match là il est il ya un
double problème il ya déjà le problème
que les si le style des joueurs et un
peu voilà n'est pas le plus excitant
mais ça c'est pas grave en fait c'est un
match serré parce que c'est intéressant
mais le problème c'est que là tu as des
sites de jeux pas intéressant couplée à
une diff à un déficit de niveau assez
évident pour pour luca
et quand tu combine ces deux choses là
mais c'est cela que j'étais d'accord
avec la personne tu vois dans le chat
qui disait sahara n'a trop fort j'étais
pas d'accord avec le sahara n'a trop
fort mais j'étais d'accord qu'il y avait
des joueurs quand tu regardais le
tableau tu vois du truc
des joueurs comme moroni quand tu à
moroni magoo dessous qui voyait aussi
rouge à alcantara tu dis ah quand même
trop gros déséquilibre la salle
virtuelle moroni compte encore quand
même temps comme une demie ou oui oui
enfin un moment donné de toute façon il
faut qu'il ya un tableau avec des têtes
de série et mais tu as du coup je sais
pas peut-être pas sa vie et s'il ya que
si gros joueurs et qui atteint 8 joueurs
m'a tant pis nitra deux matches un peu
ouais après c'est bien c'était bien
goupillé pour le tarif vent de forest
parce que tu arrives en plomb et à mon
avis c'était le même tarif ne me trahit
son point de niveau 1 mais quand tu as
oui par exemple
ryan mandat bon le match était un peu
chaud puisque vous y avait une mauvaise
connexion et qu il était deux heures du
mat chez lui mais malgré ça si tu veux
bon si la connexion avait tenu c'est un
massacre
en revanche celui qui m'a pas mal
impressionné signal sarine con qu'il
avait dit au début il est battu c'est
bien alain il a perdu contre ses
récoltes mais il a fait un gros match
si tf1 c'était le plus beau match du
speech and junior franchement c'était un
beau match et tu vois ce que j'avais ce
que j'ai vraiment ya des frictions qui
ai gagné aussi contre contre ceux qui
n'ont rien à faire dans la nuit vrai
mais meurtri fort il fait des folies oui
non mais tu vas tu as des gros à la fin
de la réunion de mars où j'en sais rien
ce que ça a donné
oui voilà en piste juste un match comme
ça mais même ces vient enfin tu as evian
nihal sarine franchement mais tu vois ce
que j'ai aimé dans le jsl moi j'ai pas
fini druck c'est ce que je voulais dire
c'est que ouais c'est un match qui s'est
construit sur la durée c'est qu'en fait
tu vas tu as une [ __ ] il a construit
sa victoire c'est bien tout petit à
petit dans le match c'est un peu comme
les matches de tennis quand c'est un peu
chaud à tous les sets mais tu sens que
en un qui est un peu devant tu vois
georgi pas et gagne 6 4 il perd 6,7 il
regagne 6 4 tu vois ce que je veux dire
mais tu sors marche prenant mes récents
qui a une petite marge et que l'autre
petit à petit fatigue et qu'en fait il
va réussir à le coincer
en fait ça fait penser à athis
hassle favre inka sauf que c'est ici
parce qu'ils gagnent à la fin quoi
marinca mais tu vas dans l'esprit c'est
un peu ça quoi c'est un peu chaud mais
qui ont quand même que bon et c'est ça
c'était plus beaux matchs idées ou sur
la caméra l'amour une passe que ce qui
tient dit en vigueur sur la caméra
ouais ça va franchement ça va
franchement juniors ils disparaissent
pas c'est plus tard c'est [ __ ] ça
vient avec l'âge
disparue mais il est de nouveau mal
autant plus at il laisse tours 8
mais il veut te dire y'a qu'une colonne
ouvert c'est la colonne des je te file
la dame où il avait payé parce que
franchement il ya vraiment ça tombe plus
pourquoi tu files tout c'est génial mais
c'est tellement fin c'est tellement
visible comme truc mais oui il a juste
donné une dame en noir le champ clos
baillie les plus dans le match mais
c'est le match où lula wendel oui je
sais j'ai vu dans le match dans le sens
où il ya une trop trop grosse différence
et nous en votre j'utilisais c6 vous
savez très bien il ya sentant de plus il
est poussé à la mine 2050 un bond
les voyants étaient au vert ouais bah
oui
malgré tout il n'a pas encore perdu un
seul marqué mais quatre cas ici six
peut-être venir n est pas très bien mais
bon si c'est grâce au beau temps bon
james qui devrait raccourcir les parties
des premiers tours je suis assez
d'accord avec ça premier tour ça
pourrait durer un peu moins longtemps
ouais bao tong avait proposé plein
d'idées mais vu qu'il ya la correcte
witch et que faut faire un truc content
ça marchait pas de l'histoire de cette
donc peut-être fait un accord d'un match
de deux heures brailsford franchement tu
pourrais faire une heure de 5 + 5 + 1 50
minutes de 3 + 1 et 25 minutes de bullet
par exemple comme ça tu pourrais
facilement réduire le match d'une heure
sans que ça sent que tu sois une loterie
jaermann qui demandent si tu penses que
moroni day is life
je pense déjà l'italien ouais tu sens
déjà puynormand il est l'homme
normalement oui encore que tu sais les
jeunes années on a séparé ce qui a fait
de remettre le français 6 c'est hyper
bien joué là de la part de parham a déjà
bien fait à 80,4 ya pas une forteresse
malheureusement bac et on va quand même
noter le rang des quatre mois je vais
découvrir l'ipad 9,7 pouces de près
parce qu'en fait avec d'amd sis à adjamé
tour des 7 6 avait aussi ces chèques les
tours 17 et des cats apparaître un
problème maintenant ne décrochant le
problème c'est comme il n'a plus de
temps en plus c'est pas trop sous
contrôle comme histoire non taille bien
envie de jouer le truc bien en contrôle
où tu pouvais jouer beaucoup de coups
vite
ouais c'est ça tu reprends têtu en vente
amazon à la pandémie de 6 buts est très
élevé au moins deux pions des puces tout
nu s'est fait plaisir nous risquent de
perdre même pas si sûr pas si sûr pierre
alpilles en d3 ok mais là faut jouer
vite comme un faux pas que tu te mettes
à une seconde phase et or y planta enfin
j'ai l'impression qu'ils gèrent pas bien
le fait que ce soit du du plus sain et
pas plus 200 m + 2 tu peux te mettre mal
mais plus simple c'est pas sûr que tu
remontes situe près move pas en fait tu
remontes pas neuf et prêt move là c'est
dur quant à la dame contre les pièces
mineurs neuf autres à kadam
bon allez l'om vers quoi ces années là
toi merci c'est le fou en ces six mois
d'abord pour ses six d'ailleurs ouais et
ensuite aux rax icg sais pas si on va
passer ça par contre ça mais loin d'être
très solide parce que la tour et coupe
le roi bah rien ne bouge tout le temps
c'est nul je pense aussi
après il peut tenter un bluff niveau
mais tu passes une borne oui oui je vous
découvrirez peut-être tour dé ce nom sur
fois qu'ils se fassent choper la dame un
moment donné sur une double hauteur de
votre iphone os même qui file à ce que
je vaux bien je vous ai pas je peux
juste nul
non mais bon moi je souhaite et je bouge
plus me payer propos de deux mots de
moreau chanson good ou suis je veux la
gagner
jean way j'adore non mais ça c'est beau
fab tête tout reste à faire nul comme ça
tant pis ah non c'est dommage on a fait
ce qu'il a pu mais web edi tout comme il
a de la marge sim avec une dame en hiver
bord et 27 81 tour f 5 m et ça faisait
un peu peur de perdre le fouet de perdre
la partie mais donc ça à faire une pause
fab
il a l'air d'aller signer avec des
moteurs de chèques par jour bah c'est ce
qu'il a dit au snos dernier bari il a le
droit quand même bordel j'ai le droit de
scolarité dans tous les je pense
notamment
mais bon après il a 19 ans même ceux
d'entre eux n'ont pas le droit non ben
oui non
il ya ok donc vous aux cinq minutes ça
ouais je remette une petite pub mais à
huit jours vernon vas-y vas-y moi aussi
je fais enfin je suis un type que j'ai
oublié de configurer j'arrive à tout de
suite l'élite mais la pub et après on
est parti en pause c'est pas facile à
mettre la pub quand t'es pas content a
pas le truc sur le téléphone mobile
alors alors alors comment faire pour
mettre la pub est en train de galérer là
en fait l'ordinateur va marche beaucoup
plus lentement
lorsque lorsqu'à le stream et beaucoup
de choses ouverte donc je mets la pub et
on revient dans cinq minutes
[Musique]
yo tout le monde c'est reparti et la
repartie tada fab thé chaud et j'ai
envie de te dire tu es chaud ronnie
l/100 ps que tu soutiens l'italien
malgré tout une fille n'a pas trouvé de
iranienne a tiré en fait c'est moi c'est
génial tu dis ça et il ya ya part à mme
thibout un petit red bull mais
haillicourt là il court il court mais
oui car oui on entend pas à temps et en
tentant pas prêt il a raison c'est en
montant le nom en tentant ok merci le
charpentier ce qu'on veut il ya
plusieurs réglages et du coup j'étais
régler ton front page avait reçu
françois hory les tons sont en fait il
était par régler partout quoi peut bien
comme il faut en fait j'avais enlevé
pendant la pause sur l'écran de pause le
départ que je crie quoi bein je suis en
fait si tu reviens comme ça tu peux
prendre tu peux parler je peux te dire
on reprend en quoi mais que j'arrive
qu'on en a plus a battu casse mais je
gâche la plume que hâter les problèmes
de connexion par affable la frappe de
parade mais attends assez reparti il
joue pas à quoi c'est sympa il était
connecté à lille et la collection rouge
allez allez allez allez à tomber la
halle et la connexion joie c'est génial
nous on est cohérent pour non mais tu
vois si les plus de connexion pendant 20
minutes ce serait quand même pas mal
alors on est comme la troupe poursuites
bah je vois pas trop d'autres solutions
pour le relancer en fait donc je me dis
il ya autant de viewer que le vélo de
moroni l'un et 2586 la frappe de bavards
mais bon quarante secondes de perdues
quand même allé jusqu ici six peut-être
non mais moi qui est ici si tu veux
faire 5 et sur des quatre fous et cinq
dames 17 grand roque t'en fiches la
santro solides épaules a aussi j'aime
pas trop je sais que ça se joue mais bon
alors non je sais pas mais je crois que
je poisse les toits que je commente la
depuis depuis une semaine
non mais tu compterait pas se réparer le
toit fermé jusqu'à j'ai commenté mgr
haas à wenger bon bah évidemment des
petites landes une heure après je veux
prendre le truc de voir chasseurs c'est
une très bonne idée mais je veux
commente pas les jours où je tombe
jetons quand même sur radjabov carrier
qui est un plus ces commissions aller à
4 1 je suis tombé là dessus je suis
tombé sur enfin je suis tombé sur du
cardiac kids de partout qua non à
d'autres cas week end là c'est un peu
too much est par contre tu peux te dire
que krainik puisqu'ils jouent et il est
sûr de l'envoyer droite aurait
franchement il est bon encore un mois
s'il atteint le maximum avec eux il
s'est fait arnaquer par cars iachini
dépôt on en fait les a dominés mais
vraiment pas indifférente au niveau
juste différence de classe c je commence
par parler poliment
tu as déjà et dépôts et cariat qui me
comté c'est rien du tout d'après et
loire nac et enfin il a donné une tour
en 1 dans une position incroyable
dommage le mexique et le tournoi non
mais c'est extraordinaire en fait c'est
une finale autour de pions contre tours
un pion les pions c'est georges et 3
contres f5 g5 bon et je sais pas ça fait
genre watch cinq jeux pas tombé six
tours ces six tours d2 vainqueur à rien
en fait mon amour y fait moreau - dépôt
il fait tomber 6 bon ben crâne il fait
tourner deux pourront épauler le regarde
il valait kramnik est dégoûté juste il
abandonne mais tu vas dépouille voulait
presque ne pas prendre la tour failli
fait il était gêné quoi mais où l ont
pas fait nul en faute ben crâne et qu'il
a abandonné presque tout de suite en
fait non mais là d'accord mais bon bah
ouais mais bon il est deux pions c'était
c'était du plus de bonbons il tournait
un peu quoi mais bon il tournait pas
méchamment blanc fait fin c'est quand il
a arrêté cramique l'aï dans l'interview
je me suis déconcentré c'était nul enfin
tu vois on ne voyait qu'il essayait me
laissait même plus en fait mais pau et
mais tu as il a perdu sur des erreurs
comme ça a du bon mais refuse d'arrêter
c'est quand même un joueur comme co
écureuils avaient galfond aussi c'est de
tourner son pion dans les doigts
ouais mais bon joueur galfond d'aussi
facture ça fait plaisir de le voir
ouais mais bon on crame knicks est au
dessus bien sûr bête est champion du
monde déjà mais mais tout ça pour dire
qu'en fait les tournois qu'ils soient
bien ou pas bien enfin ça peut aussi
beaucoup dépendre des joueurs que tu
invites à grdf déjà t'invite radjabov
enfin narita et non mais au total je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé dans sa vie
à jamais si l'été 2008 mais est elle est
battue gary ouais quand tu étais petit l
enass 2004 je dirais qu'on fasse la
vidéo d'ailleurs jour le métro 2004 je
pense de gamme mais ouais et mary qui
passait juste un gros gros gros espoirs
qu'enfin mais en plus il a percé il a
fait les candidats et des 2800 hello
kitty toy te jouer l'est indienne fager
c'était non monsieur il envoya quoi il
envoyait un mail il bouge tout d'un coup
je sais pas ce qu'il ya eu il bouge plus
une oreille
il fait des petites nul il fait rien
c'est des gambier dames c'est devenu des
faits que des trucs en fait même alors
que j'étais complètement fan du mec
c'est pour ça que l'on critique c'est
parce qu'on aime fait on a aimé en tout
cas c'est incroyable 5 500 francs des
cinq temps presse bon il c'est pas juste
pour voir quoi non plus donc de dire un
truc mais ouais donc radio je sais pas
bon après ça peut arriver que monter les
nerfs plus fragiles ou quelque chose
dans ta vie s'est marié s'en fou
maintenant je sais barbade mais mais
toujours est il que ouais manens voit
même plus trop où il en fait partie
non mais c'est dommage parce que c'est
un bon joueur ouais mais oui mais du
coup quand on est partis ouais c'est ça
c'est quand tu as dû radjabov et puis
avait une art y est faux aussi qu'ils
étaient un peu mais à la rigueur va voir
un joueur vraiment moins fort qui se
fait cartonner c'est pas forcément
embêtant parce que ça à faire valoir
il égrène mal l'amour revenir parce
qu'on est un caméléon des six ma petite
pieuvre livre qui me fait son petit tour
en b1
il des quatre des cinq qui va après plus
tard un jour méritant bien très bien
même nom évoqué beaucoup plus fort mais
on aime bien moroni quoi c'est pas c'est
pas le truc c'est juste qu'ils jouent
contre un mec c'est comme si on voyait
par m contre hikaru tiens tu es nul tu
ne sais pas jouer à dire tu as encore
perdu encore largué une pièce en un acte
eu encore mal autant as tu encore perdu
une finale nul
as tu encore raté un match en deux bah
ce serait pareil en fait ne pas tuer
c'est mal joué dommage as tu la gagnes
une partie avant ils te menace de mort
bah oui mais bon bajard dommage quoi tu
ne vas plus dormir de torbay 5h par ses
tours b 6 en fait oui les dames ce soit
mais surtout revenu québec à 3 h il veut
faire des prend et puis on branche un
ouais c'est bien joué mais ça pousse
silence ça pousse
je te rappelle cette émission ça vous le
choix des plantes
ouais mais non j'aime bien le titre et
s'il fait très attention mais je suis
passé déjà que sa fin c'est quand même
intéressant ce qu'il a mais bon mais
retenons pour le noir qui j'ai envie
d'un truc que vous triste mais tant pis
on tombe au sol c'est aussi triste c'est
vrai mais moi ils empêchaient aussi du
doigt des coupes mais là ça m'agace pour
la tour fana j'ai quand même peur dame
prend 1,4 1,8 en pin up nomme ça peut
tenir sais pas si mon bon aussi ckoi et
6 mai puis on prend mais vient prendre
même si on prend comprend faut 5 dans ce
qu'il faut faire
il pousse ses pions olala ça il pousse
tout qu'est ce que c'est il ya la
tendance est en l'air et m6
six heures chants temps il a pu t'en
occupes c'est dur de prendre le temps
d'écouter déconnecte ah oui oh non mais
ils devront vraiment le m'attendait en
plus c'est génial dure dure deux heures
si génial faut qu'ils aient des
connexions a le bon réflexe pour le
moment même avec des déconnexions se
reflétera sera quoi et ces trois années
qui s'est pris un bâton de ouais mais
bon moi j'ai pris ma tendre aussi qu'on
sait c'est dommage parce que tout
trouver tous les petits face et là tu
vois qu'il est moins fort mais la
quittant pas dicté à peu de temps tu
veux tu as tout en baies sata les clous
et ses potes je découvre mes jolies et
tous les cas les blues à ceux qui aiment
à défendre je sais faire je discutais au
club de tennis avons discuté avec marcel
alors il fait quoi marseille c'est un
joueur qui n'a aucun effet au coeur en
fête vont déjà il a tout un tas de plan
dont celles utilisées
l'instigateur du stage de tennis échec
qui veut organiser efforts très
importants sorte d'aller manger au
kiosque entre le entre la partie échec
et témiscouata et pourtant l'un des
forces et il se fait le menu fins et il
insiste
mais les school offre une formule heures
je sais pas encore mais je pense oui
mais il est très commerçant était génial
j'adore ya toujours des idées est très
très chaud mais mais du coup ce que
j'aime bien c'est que on discute du coup
tennis - discute un peu tennis et chef
du mouvement au tennis passe comme ça et
je sais comment ça se passe et on
discutait l'autre jour de contenu contre
un mec fin sur à notre niveau d'amateurs
battu contre un mec lui je crois qu'il
est il est peut-être 15
ou 2,6 bien sûr mais donc il me dit ça
arrive des fois tu avais match tu penses
que c'est serré et arrive à 40-40 dans
quasiment tous les jeux à égalité mais
me dis là en fait le mec il va mieux
jouer les points mais il sait pas qu'il
vaut mieux les points importants c'est
juste qu'il est plus fort que toi et que
sur ces points là ça va plus se voir
s'il y a plus d'enjeu quoi et je trouve
ça un peu comme aux échecs l'avant ce
match-là cercle dès que les partis c'est
un peu serré ou quad façon c'est
toujours par am qui fera la différence
ba aujourd'hui que la balle est mal
d'histoires de beauté lisse tout cas je
veux les points gagnés pour l'importance
bassin important mais je lui dis noter
qu'il disait que ça donne c'est
peut-être plus d'une supériorité
tennistique que mentale afin qu elle est
un peu dans le même délire que nous que
les gens aient toujours ah oui tu n'as
pas de mental mais en fait non non c'est
juste que tu es moins fort mais je ne
les ai pas c'était ma porte est moins
fort c'est avoir le mental que dieu il
va faire un sprint avec usain bolt a été
très fort mentalement et je suis très
fort mentalement dégage tu comprend vite
que moi alors écrit par m et iraniens
existe une culture et chicken dans les
pays arabes a vu que les échecs viennent
de perth en fait ça nous laisse donc
quelque part une certaine culture une
tradition pascutoi la question inverse
barham doit se poser tire un joueur
occidentaux italien juillet tunisie y at
il une tradition dans ces pays
dans ces camps d'ailleurs l'italie ça
c'est nouveau en fait c'est un pays
assez faible et choc
alors nouveau est pas nouveau en même
temps oui bon c'est vrai que le petit
qui veut contrôler lopez qui vient de
coûts trop nous nous tournons je vais
faire des fins ouais mais attendez vous
à sa place filin à l poutine you stay
son monde à lui c'est plutôt russes
n'ont pas coutume mais sur l'a10 miro
poutine je vois c'est s'étant déjà faire
très connus coiffe attend c'est quoi ce
titre
pandiani répond gianni et panzani il ya
eu il ya eu gréco le greco quand même
très connus fabric os il est venu sur le
game et
enfin il a posé ses couilles sur sur les
échecs en fait mais calabrais d'ailleurs
le greco mais c'est peut-être lui en
cette fin je sais pas maintenant m
poutine au sommet parce que coutrot sens
qu'à la voir mais si tu me est une peau
je vais regarder le tableau que ja et de
voir son monde au dessus bah écoute à la
pause pour comme ça ça va 10 et loire
les gens pour venir pour le nul est ce
qu'il y aura peut-être plus grand chez
l'homme il ya une culture italienne déjà
trop froide mais en fait là disons on va
prendre les chèques depuis 1950 ou 1920
s'en fiche passer du coq du coup tu veux
dire que c'est toi qui dessine les
contours de l'histoire comment ça non
mais je dirais à tous les cinémas à
salle il y avait rien wildfire c'est toi
qui écris l'histoire
exit à dire il y avait un grand maître
c'était beau des nains miquel c'est tout
on va traiter un peu de le sol quoi et
tu vois pas talent et paul jean rémy ça
peut être fabio bruno bini par l'andi
dexter a plein de joueurs mais je
pensais que j'allais rester dans le
temps le délire de thé non russe
italianisé quoi les crânes nico kasparov
s'est joué à 40 mo
j'en sais que les fans en délire comme
ça quoi mais d'un coup ils vont aussi de
se développer quoi ils ont mis un peu
d'argent une bourse et tout est là t'as
plein de nouveaux joueurs qui sont
passés grand maître mais ça peut être
vos 4 euros soit de moroni les frères en
baldoni médias ont banni wazi en mal du
tout court est bon mais les états unis
maintenant mais oui il est capital et
enfin oui non mais bien sûr même si
vivait aux états unis et tout et tout et
tout bas fabiano caruana quand même un
élevage et tenir les capitales ya quoi
et puis [ __ ] ma planche autres
intel et sony
ça pousse afin d'évoquer un taux devient
plus fort que la france en termes et
s'arrêta les solistes et eau chaude
basse
les samsung ils sont sales mais en fait
il ya vingt ans de sorte à peine tu vois
et que bonnet maintenant m qui était une
serrure absolue d'ailleurs ouais pas
toujours ok j'ai vu le monde craint que
je crois d'ailleurs une fois un hacker
blanc et fin mai donc
donc voilà ouais mais l'italie la fatwa
ils ont mis un budget pour pour les
achats qui eux qui s'impose à porter ses
fruits quoi le rapport risi quand je
suis en frappant des adoubé scellé dans
le chat ça regarde beaucoup d'amants
est-ce qu'il se sent italien qua non je
pense pas ils se sont encore s'il se
sent quand
mais bon c'est pour le chanvrier un
petit peu mais dans l'es4 brunet l'oci
dans le jeu donc alberto défaut du
luxembourgeois ou italiens maintenant
ils soient les italiennes depuis
longtemps qu'il ya machir lagrave
[Rires]
d'abord fantasy qui devait être que dès
que des dons comme ça et de trolls et un
jour je sais pas des gens qui jouent pas
d'échec
tiens je mange les gens qui connaissent
pas et j'en suis ressort que des noms
comme ça quoi
j'en ressors art in art et miéville
baiia de verdi d'ailleurs le dire mais
qu'est ce qu'ils jouent des masses mais
c'est sympa alors moment où il ya plus
que plus de monde
j'étais plus trop parti j'étais avec les
no id al yom
ah mais oui à le renouveau des échecs
italien ouais donc mais je pense qu'un
mec comme leonardo quoi mais bon
mais c'est ce qui c'est qui c'est quoi
la part de mais pas de vinci mais toi
conte vers des vieilles parties d'échecs
rsa c'est leonardo en fait là je suis
allé dans le méga base les vieilles
parties donc il y avait lopez de ségou
rare oui mon passé au rio paris n'ont
pas pu venir maintenant
matt mais la perte de pièces donc des
parties de 1572 ça c'est leonardo
voilages et retrouve son nom c'est le
petit nom c'est ça ouais leonardo il
faut reprendre revenir au psg
oui mais c'est officiel voyez un certain
lolli mélo lidar le matelot lit avec
l'option ici ces dames g7 maths c'est
encore un italien fait travailler des
citoyens de partout qu'enfin je n'en
peux plus quoi s'attelle à un moment
donné on est envahis par l'italie pas du
coup je suis envoyé dans envahi par par
mes semblables
alors du coup il ya des questions de l
caccini 1 qui demandent les joueurs sont
obligés de mettre la cam
oui chacun voit la cave de l'autre oui
pourquoi la cam est elle obligatoire
pour les voir parce que c'est sympa pour
le public et invite un peu la fin ça
évite ça évite à la triche après mais
c'est ce sens et éviter la triche mais
ça fait job
quel est le cashprize global pour le ce
tournoi alors j'ai pas le chiffre en
tête mais c'est plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de dollars au total
ça tourne peut-être dans les trente 30
mille quelque chose comme ça tu es 30 ou
[Musique]
peut-être 20000 peut-être trente mille
j'ai pas le cash prize exact mais
surtout est moins que pour le vrai
speech s avec les meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux
mais c'est comme se doit des sens je
pense moi monsieur je crois que tu as
groles trotteurs qui vous dit que
l'iranien a découpé ressent tout à fait
c'est beau quand même mon bel amour
o'neal a enfin décidé d'envoyer mais bon
le problème c'est qu'il a à 7 points de
retard non membres de l'ue peut
qu'envoyer quand le mec joue à france 2
échanges comme le signe d'un vrai plus
en plus il envoie mes mots - il joue
vite la voie l'annoncé bien même effet
c'est oui il faut faire la marque et de
seconde a répondu que voilà en fait à la
partie précédente une nouvelle fois il
perd pas si la fin des primes aux
peugeot h trois groupes bancaires g31
l'autre mais
enfin tu mets une petite épine dans la
description j'ai trois tons chauds où il
rayonne un peut qu'être la moine socle
ya plein de bonnes choses à castres mais
en fait dès qu'il a joint un peuple
autres ça s'est mal passé
c'est quand il a attaqué que ça s'est
bien passé enfin bien passée et qu'il a
eu ce qu'il a eu sa chance en tout cas
après il tente le passing c'est un 50/50
ça passe pas mon temps pis mais au moins
ils tentent quelque chose me minimaux la
foulée 5 ces relations peuvent vite
l'enquêté s'est séparé grab l'agréable
non mais là ça va nous prenons notre
personnel est sain que les blancs du
coup arrive pas jouer à 406 veut faire
maintenant que sur dame prend ira tour à
rob évitant donc tu peux trouver vite 11
jours why not sera peut-être quand même
à quatre
bah tant pis nous on prend pied on
essaie de résister ouais on peut faire
ça
le bond du coup je veux te faire pour 1
6 4 2 6 3 me contre intuitif en une
tourbière blessés sont de claude ouverte
mais elle sert à rien autant attendre
l'utile quoi il veut faire tour 1 à 4 à
5 ces bombes essonne lors du monde
pourquoi comment on est sûr que les
joueurs existe pas un logiciel pour
gagner vont déjà pour première chose
commenté sûr que même dans les matchs de
championnat du monde ils sont pas fait
greffer une puce dans l'intestin quelque
part dans le corps et qui l'utilisent
pas en fait c'est quasiment impossible
d'ailleurs en fait vous avez fait un
vraiment c'est aux échecs 28 à moi je
mettrais pas ma main au feu que dans les
tournois de haut niveau il n'ya pas des
joueurs qui est déjà très chien tu vois
je fasse c'est tellement indétectable
donc
il ya plusieurs plusieurs choses dont
déjà tu es bon tu as quand même les
caméras on compte aussi quand même sur
la décence des joueurs qui vont
peut-être en fait deux tours x et que
surtout lot c'est un peu con va faire
parce que tu as quasiment rien à gagner
c'est ça y'a pas assez dangereux en fait
c'est un déshonneur pour toute ta vie
quoi ouais faut taper le tricheur sera
que j'ai même été nulle part et tu vas
plus jamais oser regarder quelqu'un dans
les yeux ça va passer de chaud mais dans
des tournois à fort enjeu
ouais c'est un problème vraiment il ya
de bons mais bon la peur du temps ça va
encore je pense avoir des joueurs de
l'élite ce ce qu'on se soutienne bien
mais on peut en être sûr
meiway place de trouille droite c'est
que moi je passe j'ai déjà dit mais
c'est pire que le dopage en sport en
fait parce que tu t'assures la victoire
tu es vraiment sûr de gagner
alors que quand tu doc bons amis surtout
augmente les chances mais voilà tu te
demandes justes et chances du genre moi
je me dope j'ai fait un tour de france
je finis pelé d'après alors veux tu
prends fou mozart qui tue nos échecs et
d'une plus belle du monde juste en fait
très facilement sans savoir jouer d'un
seul coup en fait si c'est pas bougé des
pièces c'est pas un problème simple
juste qu'il comprend ce que leur dit lui
dit sur lui dit aux 2 4 il comprend pour
faire le pion devant droite d'occase et
voilà il suffit donc comme je disais moi
je suis pour une sévérité extrême si tu
chopes quelqu'un - testud dissuasion là
que tu te fais attraper ben c'est fini
pour toi ma vie avec courage aux échecs
après que ce soit en bas navy mais même
si tu te fais choper que sur internet
d'ailleurs facettes ou si tu l'as fait
sur internet si tu peux le faire en vrai
et puis enfin turiaf avec ce soit
vraiment parce que c'est vrai que c'est
tellement grave
bon après y'a pas mort d'homme 1 jeudi
tant pis mais c'est grave
non mais c'est grave pour les noms mais
la sanction va pas plus loin juste n'a
plus jamais le droit de jouer aux échecs
de ta vie et puis c'est tout enfin c'est
fini tu envisages tu me donnes pas d'
excuses j'avais 15 ans j'ai 18 ans je l
ai 20 attentif 1 c'est tout tu joues
plus jamais faim tu as plein d'autres
choses à que tu peux faire mental il
sait très bien
voilà deux ans en prison n'ont plus
vraiment prise en bus dans tout à fait
la logistique de mettre en prison juste
bon tu ne peux plus jouer à ce jeu c'est
je pense le ps et même très bien
pourquoi enfin tu fais quelque chose
peut-être de plus intéressant dans tag
n'y a pas d'âme français 54.7 des
fragments des tours points 8 ouais non
mais attends j'ai quelques dames 35 pour
prendre 7 points 7 pardon à sa possible
et dépenser 5 pour prendre
bon il a toujours ce sétois et le
contremaître et le contraire était aussi
bon à ce titre que sans plus
cette partie ballet va la gagner là bas
son nouveau bail il a l'air bien parti
que la faille est une pièce contre un
pion ça se calme pas mal mais vous même
une pièce entière ça va si je peux être
utile tout est bon je trouve bon bah ils
jouent les chocs moderne au travail un
problème cinq tours yaman ce matin en
bourse comme bon ça marche aussi km
attendent ces normes connais tellement
de matches dans ce match c'est rare bon
ben on voyait tout jusqu'au bout puisque
vous appréciez ouais ça revient et
revient à six points a enfin une petite
sicilienne fable à ça a peut-être un peu
s'animer
ouais alors mon fo ne s'est pas le c'est
fou j'ai cinq ans mes amis parham
spécialiste de l'arroseur d'eric
chirugien je vous la vente a vécu et
c'est reparti j'ai pris six structures
là alors juste si je sais pas si ça pose
ça ne te découvre je dire dans cette
structure là j'ai des ambitions ça serve
aussi si elle me les a eus je suis pas
tour celui des trucs pesant mais n'y a
pas fait a fait retour d un essai jouer
pour 5 voix ces deux mots ni de tarif 2
sinon de ses positions là pour le
prouver si c'est un peu ouais tu peux
aussi j'étais de jeu qui est des singes
imagine avec si on te prends-tu reprend
2 e
il était pas déçu parce que ça va
tourner vers la colonne eux pour faire
pression sur recettes tué mille fois en
d4
il veut qu'elle ait des cinq je pense à
penser les petits avantages
des bombes larguées dessin cafu prend
les dames france et demain on va
préparer donc faut préparer et wars 2
mais est ce que tu penses que moroni et
si loin en fait ce qui me paraît très
loin mais en réalité si on passe le film
du match après l'autre a peut-être
appris l'histoire que le 40e rétro battu
car comme 6,09 à lausanne on t'as raison
c'est juste que je voulais relancer
redonner un peu de vie au match et je me
dis peut-être que au terme de niveau il
est pas si loin il peut remonter mais en
fait c'est vrai que dès que ça a été
chaud après peut-être une petite baisse
de régime de par am c'est dur je vous
dis vas foncia conac a en fait qui
contentent défoncées de asa de faire des
options de porto perrier de tulle
milliers ils adorent et teyran une faute
et gasnier 1
il n'y a pas longtemps et il est perdu
contre un mec ait dit oui je verrai
contre lui mais il est très mauvais il
est nul farbos et social parce que
j'adore n'a cassé qui clashe plus
sais-je encore quand il perd contre
quand ils gagneront le mac est nul mais
il en rajoute pas trop mais c'est hyper
sénat oui c'était une mère de total le
mec ne s'est pas joué face et c'est bien
d'être encore plus énervé quand tu perds
et dire que le mec encore plus nuls quoi
parce qu'il t'a battu c'est le bon quoi
j'aime bien cette mauvaise foi absolue
je pense qu'il est encore pire que moi
j'adore parisien je pense qu'il va
beaucoup plus loin
noël ou non mis les biens d'occasion
mais j'aime bien mais il fait marrer
mais enfin on s'est marré des fois tu
quittes ovidie oui oui on veut perdre
toi autrichiens hongrois déchets qui va
voler une banque
enfin je sais pas mais quoi qu'il en
soit j'ai tout suspens en ligne à partir
à voler autre chose ailleurs c'est pas
la norme est le problème si l'on vibre
pas sur l'iran autre chose mais ce débat
navy piolenc ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre là dedans
les gens pour pourquoi pourquoi pas une
telle sévérité et pourquoi je suis
d'accord avec lui c'est qu'en fait c'est
très facile à faire et c'est très
difficile à détecter
donc en fait le mélange de facilité
d'exécution et de difficultés de de même
même de suspicion quelque part mais au
delà de la suspicion de prove ajoie fait
qu'en fait si t'as pas une grosse
sanction c'est facile tu as pas de gros
risques
c'est vraiment tellement facile limitons
incitant vote bah oui donc c'est pour ça
il faut vraiment des sanctions fortes
pour que la dissuasion t'empêche pas ce
que déclare la guerre à la france domine
quand vous déclarez on verra bien ouais
c'est pareil quoi enfin tu peut tricher
ou sous le choc
si ce film ne sera plus une pièce
d'automne voilà faut le savoir voilà il
faut que ce soit vérifiée à l'après
cercle quand il ya un prêt et il se fait
choper faut oui non mais après faut pas
enfin faut que ce soit prouvée sopot
c'est juste une suspicion parce que
c'est facile aussi ça c'est le problème
aussi c'est que tu as des gens ils font
des super tournoi
et tout de suite oui c'est ça ouais
c'est après la suppression de partout et
a aussi le droit de bien jouer sa phobie
mais bon si c'est avéré s'avérer pour
moi c'est fini on sait qu'ils vont
commencer possible il suffit juste
d'avoir un complice tu peux tu peux
regarder la vidéo de vlad thatcher eyebe
camatchy tard oui montre mon boulot mais
un tout une peu tout petit petit
sonotone dans le dans l'oreille un des
textes afin quasiment indétectable on la
sait juste montrer que technique et co
plus il a juste un mec qui l'appelle
dessus et qui lui dit les coups à jouer
c'est enfin c'est très simple la
fatigante mais l'histoire de la plus
grosse et pourquoi pas et donc oui pour
le sort du mak des chaussettes face
c'est pas juste qu'il partait dans les
chaussées chose a atteint ya tout un
historique derrière donc c'était ivanoff
un bulgare qui qui a jamais été trop
long de sa vie enfin j'aime parce qu'il
a déjà eu deux mille voitures est en
fait ils signent et la famille éprouvée
de qui cartonnait tout le monde ah non
il cartonnait tout le monde totalement
pas il battait les grands malades et/ou
et il n'avait pas 13 ans tu vois au bout
il approuve
c'est bien ça donne provenant il est
déjà bien l'avantagé est juste il
apparaît une fois il est un atout
radotant à trois tournois et en fait à
un moment on ne comprenait pas qu'on
personnes pour un con et riche parce que
tout le monde la valve avec wafa c'était
juste évident pour tout le monde mais il
faut prouver et auquel on est romancé
oui peut-être un truc dans ses
chaussures parce que ça qui bougeait pas
un poil de s'attabler machin et à et
donc moment des bas montre où tes pieds
quoi après un moment une fouille donc il
a refusé ça suffit à le dire et du temps
mais je pense s'est passé vous prouver
qu'ils lancent à pourvoir histoire en
réalité juste bon bah t'as pas voulu
redonner aux habitants de satin droit de
faire mais présence turque officiel
dietrich est il juste de sérieux doutes
pour lui mais oui mais bon c'est
vraiment simple ajuste aussi la présence
de ces chaussettes ou le 18e tricheurs
c'est qu'il ya un énorme historique de
sur plusieurs mois avant quoi mais là
c'est un peu calme simple calme et la
non ces histoires avec les téléphones et
mach 1 % après le truc c'est que c'est
souvent des amateurs en fait il faut oui
c'est plus souvent des amateurs que les
projets ce qu'en fait les pros
évidemment moi tu gâches ta carrière
après il ya eu les géorgiens et machin
il osera enfin ses katas c'est pas fort
alors que les c4 si pas mal c'est patent
prend b3 puis une fourchette était
toujours évitèrent il est donc je
n'avais quand même bien battu a tout
d'une puce de faire tourner trois points
sont les tours suivants s'assoit
troisième rangée way story
tu vas faire tordre et 3 un dessin
autour des 3 et 4 après une classique et
un autrichien jeunes d'europe jeunes
j'en ai entendu parler mais je me
rappelle plus trop nuls 3 échecs ont
varié andrew p en d3 et des puits où le
jso
une nouvelle histoire ils remontent à
plus 7
enfin bon moi fois la panne ou qu'ils
ont les lois et puis on va d'autre part
et hop c'est marrant mais je serais
assez sévère bravo c'est compliqué aussi
c'est notre avis après on aura tous
trompés aussi non chacun son avis un
voile à ma droite les avis divergent
mais bon c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
mais ouais mais du coup dans les gros
tournois jarre olympiades ou quoi c'est
vrai que le sécurité sont très très très
serré cause de l'équipe de france c'est
un peu monsieur avons initié la triche
aux olympiens de moi je trouve ça très
bien en fait tu passes par un portique
ils ont des garettes pour scanner et que
c'était un truc ne pas rentrer indeep
taille de l'extérieur quoi si tu veux
boire tâche est dedans nous les trucs
certifié s'est acheté un coca c'est un
vrai copain est certifié sakho a
certifié les autres noms n'ont pas
d'autre raison d'être que c'est une
canette de coca a rempli deux on sait
pas on ne sait pas qui est un logiciel
de 5 tonnes
on ne sait pas le nom juin trucs dedans
je sais pas
donc voilà donc là où il va se traîne
mais non mais c'est l'équipe de france
soit la première à avoir triché à une
olympiade peut-être même la seule non
bas à moins qu'ils aient détruit qu'on
soit au courant et mai mais bon j'aime
bien des fois remettre la réalité en
place que sur enfin on est français on
aime bien sûr faire elle sera tout le
monde mais bon en gros là si on parle
toujours des bulgares des machins des
trucs mais en fait vont moins bien géré
le quand même le cas le plus connu c'est
quand même un français a enfin laissé
toute cette gloire quoi c'est beau quand
même quoi quelque part comme personne à
rester une personne n'a réussi depuis à
refaire en somme les salles quoi nous ne
dominons de notre lumière quoi dégage
voilà un petit des trois sacrifiés
options on s'active de partout sinon pas
ce qu'est le 5 et d'amd 4
donc je crois que ça mène à rien là qui
risque d'amener cattapan de faire
tourner trois mais ça sert à rien mais
c'est joli
ouais alors est ce que c'est bien le
détour au centre comme ça
ouais t'as lu un livre de sud rail
tandis que ces patriotes fer à 4h quatre
tours h43 à tour à trois maîtres se
faire tour des trois trous 3 rapidement
mais collaborons déjà vous voyez là où
je lui fous contours web on sait mais
bon après c'est entre les mailles du
filet ouais tu passeras wifi ils te
disent oui c'est pas terrible quand même
parce que tu étais pièces ont du mal à
sortir derrière en fait mais bon je suis
pas convaincu
je vais quand même essayer incessamment
sous peu vers pena en tirant rousseau
que cette extraordinaire que donc
donc des trois messages anelka chi lan
sur quoi ils travaillent les nouveaux y
débuter il s'est dit oui quel monde
pourri second décès savane on est là
quoi nam après on parle de cas isolés
quand même oui c'est pas pas toujours
isolées en fait c'est très rare mais bon
c'est juste que tu posait la question de
faire du coup un speech n'a jamais eu de
problème bon ne pas qu'on sache ou non
mais je suis franchement on nous qui
avons commenté fable tous les matchs de
ce pitch n'a fait aucun doute
franchement il n'ya jamais eu l'ombre
d'un doute bonjour le plus fort gagne en
photo c'est ça pour fait que fish c'est
un truc n'y a jamais de surprise
quasiment mais en fait le fait que sur
une partie pour une reprise mais quand
tu joues 30 fois en fait un moment
critique me remise est sûre qu'ils
trichent pas génial qui se fasse
attraper pour friche à la fin du match
et oui tu as triché dans la seule partie
que tu as gagné c'était pas fakih qui
coache l'équipe de france à l'époque de
l'histoire de l'équipe de france à bon
voilà du coup il ya encore un peu mieux
avec avec les blancs désolé alors est de
ne pas commenter le match à fond mais
vraiment enfin j'ai l'impression que
c'est plus intéressant de discuter un
peu de tout et de rien des chèques en
général des jeunes hommes peuvent faire
attaquer le pion aux c est faire des 4 b
side attaque des minorités avec son fou
gedo qui veut jouer à fond déjà fait
ouais ouais
la réponse à tour ces trois ou quatre
arrêts c'est pas mal par des structures
de force et le 500 m le socle des cinq
ans après faut voir si y'a pas des
fouilles 6 des marchands après faut
calculer un c'est autant prêts quoi le
fameux tempo pour italien bombay 4 doit
partir tu peux peut-être commencer par
foulée 6 pour 1 m la tour sur une
mauvaise case au niveau de saddam trois
mosquées est-ce qu'en fait-on 17 elle
bloque le fou et on sait 7
et pas très un passé auquel m haies en 8
es petit tu m'en fous amusez-vous b6
gnafu et 6 non c'est bien tu bloques tu
fixes bien et donc tu tues tu frise le
jour est adverse - fois qu'on est ici
veut faire des quatre un jour après mais
j'aimais bien le plan juste b4 bessin
mais c'est pas les deux sont possibles
après dans ces structures là mais je
trouve qu'il est vraiment fort près mme
parham un contexte est morose mais c'est
pour ça que je crois des masses elle
revient bien me renie pas j'étais
content pour lui en fait mon fils fait
défoncer la seconde et 4 août
non mais c'est dur et saluer monsieur p
soit dans le chat qui peut pas rester à
quai salut à toi bonne soirée et l épia
bientôt qu'on espère prépare toi mais
c'est au ris parce que jamais séduire
ses matchs à sens unique c'est dur non
mais sa passe est qu est ce qu un brin
dire que déjà que le mec est plus fort
même si tèlman mais un manque de glace
en a marre du bourny je pense idées -
visign le match et puis je n'ai pas
allumé la télé motion pizza les clichés
franchement merzeau même nom mais bon
c'est parce qu'il est italien qui avait
mangé une pizza c'est ça non ce que je
veux je vous sautera son nom mais je
vois je vois les clichés de l'italien
qui mange qui mange qui mange sa pizza
en faisant un peu de plomberie quoi un
mot enfin gers et ses clichés quand même
un peu grave quoi fin juin mais bon
c'est vrai il n'a pas le droit de manger
d'eau et pour le coup j'ai ris
on l'aimé pour les pizzas quoi il n'ya
pas de 17 pouces et safari si si je
voudrais bien détaillé lokua donc non
mais bon c'est rare et après on s'est
quand même
projet de vie pour sortir l'autre matin
fodé sylla s'est repris en m'attendre
c'est horrible heures mais bon enfin
assez dur quoi fin moroni la façade bien
humiliant un moment donné non alors là
il ya cécilia c'est simple et gaye cissé
qui existent en jambes sont sur la
caméra id michal non pas si franchement
il est mal amoureux non mais je joue en
bavent avoir va cherche bougez pas je
sais pas où tu peux rien donc qui est
sûrement un coup très intéressant nous
occupions fuck coûteux du jeu
franchement suivre son visage je pense
qu'il a envie de chialer
non mais je comprends peu de temps
agissements mais je crois qu'il ya du
lourd à hyères dégoûté franchement il
est récurent et chanteront regarder que
la cam l'a d'ailleurs il enlève la cam
des mouvements annoncés
franchement et je cours en stage au
mileu twitch bains douches sur la chaîne
je me plais en fête loué le chat tous en
général ils voient pas leurs produits
nous raconte julio cesar ils viennent
ils viennent d'enlever la tête en face
il ya nos médecins oui parce qu'en fait
il s'entiche à du lourd et du pouy part
du match de demain à 19h est beaucoup
plus intéressant d'heure comme match up
bah oui mais déjà il est dur à plus
forts qu'eux moroni et liang moins fort
que mag ou douces ou donc une rupture au
sein d'un milieu droit il est pas mal du
tout très solide ils peuvent enfin de
bons joueurs toulonnais dans nombre à
lyon pas et où on dort liang américain
américains et trois jours et qu'il sera
devenu plus fort plus vite enfin il est
déjà très fort très jeune je sais pas je
les ai vus à stockholm et il m'a pas une
tranche de pain il a fait un très bon
temps mais c'est pas là y'a rien à dire
mais en fait je m'attendais vraiment un
tu as remarqué mais faute à des gamins
ils progressent à cette action qui
régresse après même carrément je peux
voir les caméras mais tu vas voir nos
moroni lahouel ans mais c'est horrible
phase sais pas si celle du lourd ou six
d'or mais c'est un mélange des deux ben
oui se frotte les yeux je mets les
liqueurs et larissa soir mais je
comprends pas c'est trop loin match on
dit fait défaut c'est un autre match -
qui continue à se faire défoncer en fait
versement de fouet 5à puis on prend des
quatre jeux sous les e-bonds deux façons
je fais 20h d'échec par jour bombe
tout va bien pour la polio match et rick
notre côté je vois c'est fini en fait
c'est surtout autre qui va arriver enfin
kg 3 francs des deux rois prend des
options prendre trois mois chose qu'il
faut si c'est un hasard si fausse ça
vient vraiment de tous les côtés comme
si c'était elle
non mais je n'en mets c'est terrible
pour pour lui car franchement ça devrait
sur son visage
je choisis les marques l'époque ouais il
est marqué un il faut rester un arbitre
qui viennent et il te fait te fait
compter jusqu'à 10 tu n'arrives piloter
non je ne peux pas te laisser reprendre
le match puis si tu dis ici je veux y
retourner quand même quoi mais tu es
foutu compte plus quand même que tu
étais mal quoi non mais le truc en fait
c'est qu'on n'a pas l'habitude aux
échecs de ce genre foot tu es mené 4 0
ça se sentait minutes savons matin une
demi heure à jouer mais en fait tu as
déjà que nous avons été petit à blaise à
toute ta vie quoi enfin si tu dessus en
mettant de la défaite qua non mais
j'arrivais coton pourri mais en fait aux
échecs site à une situation dans une
partie devrait juste abandonne et puis
tu finis tu rentres à tourner au duel
tourne chez toi entreprend un verre tu
vois tes potes importe mais là en fait
de te forcer à te mettre la tête sous
l'eau c'est un truc qu'on connaît pas et
chaque pas aller dans d'autres sports
déjà c'est pas mal mais mais là en fait
on n'a vraiment pas l'habitude elle ce
serait génial de faire un croquis sur
les échecs mais c'est juste défoncé 50,0
quoi si tu vois il complètement défoncée
à la fin c'est leur maxi et tout comme
un fou essayez prix des droites quoi il
revient toujours où il revient quand
même et puis remonte le match patata
atteint 7 à la musique après quoi 50
1,52 quoi il ya une des pièces en a il
est très très chaud ce serait génial en
profite dans la gestion des fonds c'est
après tu le vois courir y courir et zou
des taxis sur son téléphone il a fait
quoi où deux escaliers parce que çà il
prend les escaliers en résolvant des
tactiques voix sur son téléphone
je dépose le rush 0 pédalera je suis
voix 50 60
tu dis plus haut qu elles veulent sur
leur corps faille très heureux quoi
après il vient il ya eu le match et
c'est génial
les gueux l'adria les plus jeunes
biarrots km et avec reed mois avec rides
mais avec wave avec le monde en fait
ouais
et du coup c'est un concept intéressant
contre tout le monde
non mais c'est sous-estiment sûrs votre
qui viendra web à un dragon boat réforme
la drogue est très fort mais le pied
prendre 4 qui va arriver
ma famille et je souhaitais de plus que
fin mai maintenant on est ok c'est bien
bonne franchise et j'ai bien aimé la
crise la saison repris parce que vous
allez bien c'est qu'ils en retirent le
truc c'est bien sûr car l'esprit il ya
toujours le personnage de rocky
jean-louis serait pas pareil que oui non
à rijban acteurs il joue bien le rôle
donné au mieux à val d'or qu'on mérite
mais ça c'est des beaux films merci
polonais dans le et dans le chat pour le
bret maire c'est possible on sait jamais
mais très beau film aussi c'est les
avenger ah ben oui c'est comme ça alors
ce jeu c'est le pavé
où j'aime bien armé oui non mais ça va
croquer aux échecs serait marrant vas-y
on prépare un scénar voulait investir
dans ce propos projet junior lui
cinquante mille euros
[Musique]
rapidement non mais ils galèrent avec sa
pièce de plus mais je pense qu'en fait
plus personne et dans le match que
soient les commentateurs les joueurs faf
cela fait ce qui laisse qui rament à
gagner sur l'australie l'a mise au fond
de quête il va taper v2 avec de ses
mémoires pour il aurait pu y est depuis
longtemps savent que j'ai même l'ordi en
fait qui sucre et c'est génial
bordeaux a perdu son talent pareil à
plus tard
attend il va se prend il va se prendre
un tour prend b2 ou un truc maintenant
on va les faire mieux ou le mat je peux
il n'y a pas d'âme le jeune homme n'est
pas d'un projet 6 et 3 n'ont ils pas
fait ici là il tombe cette position
était finie comme si je sais c'est
marrant me ledoux bien c'est qu'il est
proche de 3 ans fait pas non mais par am
je vraiment bien neuf ou autre part à me
faire un bon match il n'y a pas de
soucis monsieur par rapport au niveau de
jeu de parade c'est juste que mon ami un
ami un poids lourd face à un fois les
restes tu vois là même où des fautes
esquive tenté pour les jeux les séries
dans les cordes dès l'automne non mais
c'est relie fergie c'est quand même fou
l'écart entre de gm et le truc en fait
si on a déjà parlé de femmes aussi c'est
qu'il faudrait faire un nouveau titre il
ya une grosse différence entre gm à 25
50 et gm à 27 ans fait face et 28 et à
28 c
aravane qui montre ses poids lourds au
premier sens mais c'est parce que parra
mais super g m
il n'y a pas de titre de super vilain
mais si on considérait qu'un super jm
c'est un mec qui a dépassé un jour les
2007 il le serait il les a pas débat
c'est peut-être mais bon si je crois
qu'il est et 2007 100,05 virtuel ouais
ou non votre public
on veut un réflexe fois pas juste un
site qui te compte des trucs
est-ce que c'est prévu par la cid de la
fidh de créer des titres intermédiaires
je crois pas mais je pense comme ça ça
peut avoir du sens mais en tout cas
super bien même ce serait bien quoi du
coup tu pourras me remotiver quoi on
joue gros 2007
mouais pas gagné non mais on va te voit
aussi quelques jours quand tu des grands
maîtres plus trop d'objectifs
en fait c'est un jeu enfin on a déjà
parlé souvent avec toi mais c'est un jeu
un peu étrange dans le sens où dans
plein d'autres disciplines en fait
paraître juste de jouer faire tu
continuer à bosser dans le truc ou quoi
mais tu arrêtes de jouer en fait alors
que ces chèques ouais c'est un peu il ya
plus fins et pas assez bizarre c'est
bizarrement organisé et donc ouais t'as
plus trop d'objectifs un monde et c'est
normal what the vault demi heure se
dévoyer là je t'aime bien joué quand
même mais notamment à la hargne que ce
que tu as pu avoir cours
ben c'est normal ouais toujours besoin
de ta vie tu as déjà je te demande
partie de mes choix
un peu comme urt à ça près mais tu as un
mur face tu joues pour les titres par
exemple tu es heureux champion de
canaille champêtre qu'à dax en fait il
se chauffe pour des petites mascottes
[Musique]
mais les petits open ils s'en fichent
complètement il joue ça complètement
tranquille mais il se fait au tout ça et
les contrôles ouais jeux olympiques
asiatiques ou quoi mais comme ça vient
de jeu pour les titres bien sûr et aussi
si wayne était calé la coupe du monde je
conduis autre chose pourquoi ça ces
colonnes en fait il se battait pour ce
que fait un choix déjà la qualifie se
battait vraiment en fait il voulait se
qualifier qua non non ça c'est cool bien
sûr je commence une motivation interne
en fait il y trouve ce genre de
motivation mais les pilotes open hack il
avait joué dans sa ville où quoi enfin
il fait n'importe quoi et peut-être
perdu 20 30 points elo il arrive juste
pas en fait je peux comprendre
bon là pour couler pas mal de rognan
ouais mais pourquoi il dono d'esprit je
crois qu'il n'a pas vu juste après par
la tête tu vas faire ah ouais non issue
il fut totalement nouveau ça allait très
bien se défendre des six fours qui est
des quatre avant enfin n'importe quoi un
petit tour à des huit un petit qui est
des quatre tout allait très bien la
bombe ayant fait il ya des compensations
pour son tour de moins mais dépasse en
savoir un peu moins juste voir la même
chose avec un plongeon de 6 du coup à
une cache chikhi monde 6ème vais le peut
un jour devenir champion du monde à
écoute c'est théoriquement possible moi
j'avais fait une évaluation avec les
mecs l'autre jour tu sais et je crois
que j'avais donné j'ai dit qu'il y avait
une chance sur 50 je crois de mémoire
moi ça alors je sais pas si ces heures
où normal mais pas trop quand même
on avait calculé en avait multiplié la
chance de qualification aux candidats
par la chance de gagner les candidats
par la chance de battre car ce n était
pas du genre à une telle chose sur 40
sur 50 quelque chose comme ça non c'est
déjà pas de carlson en match mais leur
dieu oui je joue mieux puisqu'il a
jamais jours le problème c'est que même
si tu fais nul et chiant rapides et très
forts et donc tu te rends rapide en
général mais je soutiens les plus
cadence lente et 2 2 qu'ils aient déjà
pascal il fut candidat il faut les
gagner donc c'est très compliqué en mai
sas dans le dans le possible en fait
parler de niveau mais le niveau en fait
c'est encore pire parce que le niveau de
carn scène je pense que la haye c'est
plutôt cent de chance en fait je pense
pas qu'il soit devenu impossible
mais après le prendre le titre c'est
possible après jouer au niveau de carl
ça ne va pas dans quel monde c'est
possible mon pote c'est plus facile
d'être champion du monde que meilleur
joueur mondial oui oui dans votre boîte
champion du mouvement gros pas à
dépenser le meilleur joueur du monde
c'est plus dur non mais souhaite que
j'avais victoire de petrossian tête en
fait j'ai vu les gens du monde mais je
pense qu'il n'a jamais été libre 1
mondial sam était vraiment mon pétrole
mais il est très bon on va te le truc
c'est que repousser au ghana il est très
très bon deux à trois cents photos
question même 3 quoi oui non c'est fini
mais en fait hors match s'ils perdaient
pas quoi tout un lycée sont sûrement son
iron quiron il était hyper solide mais
en fait oui ça fait il s'en foutait de
faire nul en général donc en fait dans
les eaux européennes c'est un peu chiant
de faire nul parce que battus parfois un
autre qui le font à ce mal d'entre eux
m'ont dit qu'à laisser je le mets dans
un match vu quant à ta tête votre donc
fait des nuls ça change tout mais non
c'est un grand joueur c'est toujours
bien de lire le livre python stratégie
en fait c'est il ya comment il s'appelle
il ya sous taf qui leur commandent
vachement aujourd'hui sur facebook
mais bon ouais fait il dit petrosyan
genre très intéressant comme ça alors
c'est en voisin il est mort depuis
longtemps il aurait eu 90 ans
aujourd'hui
non en fait il dit quoi il ya un truc
intéressant et guise et son livre a été
très sous-estimées famille les parents
sous-estiment en union soviétique il est
très respecté mes failles quand même
sous-estimé par rapport aux autres dit
mais c'est aussi par le fait que son
style inimitable est très difficile à
imiter justement et met donc dit oui
très intéressant de lire enfin il dit
extraordinaire machin est en train de le
lire donc mais jamais j'avais déjà été
assez impressionné quand j'avais lu son
chapitre dans ma grille prédécesseur il
de caspar c'est très bien mais mes
hockey et mais ça pour dire que moi je
pense que
il n'y avait pas de vélo à l'époque
façon mais que même il va pas été no1
mondial qu'est ce qu'on peut donner des
noms de la relève française qui pourrait
être derrière mv à l'aube on sait pas
encore si la non mégalo on peut pas
demain qu'on brière éventuellement ok
mais c'est encore un peu plus de baisses
ces jeunes mais déjà là c'est disons le
plus prometteur mais bon c'est énorme en
fin de vie peut se passer quelque chose
mais il est beaucoup trop petit encore
mais après le truc c'est que dans les
plus âgés je veux dire mon coin il ya
juste personnes sans manquer de respect
qu il y aura des joueurs qui deviendront
grands maîtres pourquoi mais ça ne sera
pas la relève de nouvelles ça arrivera
un jour c'est sûr on ne peut pas savoir
qui quoi non mais là je pense que mes
joueurs qui ont 16 ans 17 ans 18 ans dit
il n'a pas juste non ce ne sera pas dans
ceux là donc c'est quelqu'un de plus
jeune que peut-être quelqu'un qui
pompent en bestiaux bon du coup ce rock
opposé à mener ça se passe pas très bien
une nouvelle fois pour gérard sans que
les pions de deux pages l'aramon lourde
plus vite
d'ailleurs la france un petit recul au
classement des nations
je crois qu'on était 4e de travail a pas
si longtemps wen c4 5e pendant un bon
moment 4 5 6 sur en semaine et de la
chebba sur le court 10e ou 11e
on est à notre place 1 bah oui pas de
truc c'est que les gens à un moment un
trait tig ou suse et tous ne relève et
des gens qui qui remplace et qu'une
émulation un truc satyam écoute ça
reviendra peut-être ou pas on s'en tient
aux chambres se disent on suivra
d'italie non mais oui va je ne sais pas
par moi en fait pour suivre les échecs
c'est un des seuls trucs coup j'ai pas
vraiment besoin de deux nationalités
j'ai besoin de courant tournoi où il ya
des enjeux genre les candidats et
machins et tout on a déjà parlé mais en
fait ça me dérange pas de pas sur un
joueur français n'ont pas d'ailleurs en
fait
genre dont j'étais le plus jeune c'était
kasparov n'est pas nouvelle au type ba
oui il est quelle soir contre l'autriche
espère à ce point en fait moi aussi je
crois non mais en fait c'est ça c'est
que quand tu aimes vraiment le truc
après c'est un peu différent mais c'est
ok comme fait d'ailleurs dire que le
conte importe quelle france heures je
donne pas soudé un français puisque tu
aime le beau jeu
non mais même en coupe davis où j'étais
très content que rogers gagné la finale
à lille 2015 a battu gasquet est assez
bien joué ça tours cellulaires va faire
un tour b 8 et tour ces deux noms mais
la vieille joueurs puisque le front des
trois c'était bien joué pour couper la
liaison des pièces non mais je viens en
fait face à quoi bon pour pas trop de ce
qui ce serait chic et mes deux titres
audio madame c4 est sûr times et 4
passes quand même attendre c'est que je
me sens très sûr b3 tu fais tout reprend
des deux est d'amasser deux passes a
encore gagné mais attends reprend des
deux justes oui ou deux et trois corps d
un et deux du canon oui c'est terrible
c'est terrible ce terrible ça prend
l'eau de toutes parts à la puce 11 ça
devient non mais il va il va chialer un
bâtiment sis à chalais quoi c'est génial
qui a un contrat quoi j'en rachète pas à
20 points tu vas fort et quoi offrir un
contrat chess comme el pueblo à un
moment donné pour que les mecs restent
motivés quoi on ne sort le contrat bien
ri qui donc j'aimerais avoir l'avis de
gilles fabien sur les menaces qui
sortent genre trop peur qu'elle menaçait
les menaces dont elle a été victime ou
autre chose
sachant que sa part d'un d'une blague
ces deux mèches tactique à rousset c'est
moi de dire de quel plat qu'on parle
passé
les mecs menaces de mort quand même pas
non mais je veux dire de façon je
l'écris au jour sur les discordes un
mois ils carrure menacé de mort et voit
enfin c'est votre problème
beau palmarès
j'ai dit ça une fois au club de tennis
un mec quoi tu vois il caressait de
maricopa aux échecs c'est pâques et
hikaru n'ya en fait on s'est entre
autres les mecs sains enfin c'est un
troll on ne sait pas quoi ouais c'est
vrai en plus ce qui est génial c'est
qu'il a supprimé la vidéo d'une au fait
qu'en fait elles sont primés la vidéo il
me menace de voir passer du coup ça ça
fait encore plus augmenté la légende du
truc non depuis la vidéo a été supprimée
enfin fou alors il reste il reste plus
que 2 me de trois plus simple et j'ai
envie de dire c'est pour me libérer une
libération quoi donc
carpanin grilles d'accès la menace est
plus forte que l'exécution d'ingo fitch
- valable
ça reste très fort très longtemps c'est
me voilà comment il va perdre si génial
de se poser cette question en fait pas
comment jouer mais comment perdre tes
skis de monsieur qui s'appelle que
mangou de loup il devrait sortir la
phrase de vlad quoi toi t'es nul moi je
suis moi je suis pas le morphisme
indiquera que je sais me 13,2 jeter
humilié non mais tu vois ce sera quand
même alors le droit quand tu me avec
comme ça te foutent de sa gueule doivent
être approuvées par les ventes en échec
par toulouse dont le très normal tout ce
qui se passe en photo voilà enfin désolé
les mecs hein c'est juste un peu dur de
se passionner pour ce match et
honnêtement aya double attaque mais la
seule crise et 7 et j'ai six cases à mme
lagarde et de l'eau fake le nom
maintenant mais c'est juste fini la
partie la femme je veux dire le chat
roux une nouvelle attaque
en fait il met à ce qu'a laissé cette
émulation g6 baby baby
hélas le détroit et france sait pas trop
pourquoi moi pour le panache blanc de
vue ou manger de cavaliers non il
demandait s'il y avait des grosses
révisions au delà des russie usa hockey
je crois qu'il y avait guère fondé
adamski s'apprécier pas trop parce que
je crois que ma copine ou adams ou femme
il ya un truc comme ça ni longtemps
peut-être que maintenant et l'eau est
passée sous les ponts et que ça va
passer de la vieille histoire
peut-être qu'il pensait 3 que notre
climat de haine je me disais ce qui va
se le prendre il ay ay ay krainik
topalov qui se détestaient
ça a pas la main shirov kasparov eu des
petits trucs comme ça m'a presque
issa mbaye samb a su reconquérir à
prendre cavale et andy françois jacq
blessés c'est le cas ça les a pris et
peut-être d'autres trucs avec fouet 4g
six matchs avant de façon il était
minimale de partout et moi je veux le
voir chialer en fait beaucoup chez
dessau bassil chiale quoi vous nous
plaisir c'est sympa comme ruth weale ans
mais bon ça ça me remet pas en cause qui
soit sympa mais il s'est mis les
appareils peut tous faire prendre la
fuite et la meuse 5 déjà le spoil garder
le pouls des six qui redonne portée il
va doubler les tours ils arrivent de
tous les côtés
il joue vraiment bien voilà il est ce
pas de chance on peut en fait pas très
spectaculaire mais c'est un peu du
rouleau compresseur
ouais moi je suis dire ça pour en salle
elle s'est un peu de comprendre que rien
ne soit pas vous faire payer des soldes
par le jury 4 octobre et le match
camions man est quasi mathématiquement
gagné déjà des noms mais pas au premier
sens du terme et genre en se disant que
les parties de bull est la dure trois
minutes en moyenne
enfin c'est rare d'avoir 18 départs 10
particules est en fête
donc en gros s'il ya une salade match
est déjà terminé et donc du couteau qui
avait un peu tous les joueurs tu penses
qui est favori doit par sarah n'a
évidemment mais dans le
si si tu enlèves l'épouvantail à écouter
à fuir ou jack quand même j'étais bien
impressionnant et assez vian qui a été
bien surprenant bon sahara n'a quand
même s'il n'est pas été mauvais mais
moins impressionnant oui en fait ceux
qui sont qualifiés sa siens après je
pense que les quarts de finale seront
intéressants et il ya en fait je pense
ou ici règle ses problèmes de connexion
il est quand même bien hexion mais parce
qu'il a vraiment mis un gros score que
l'effet genre 19,9 ou quoi contenir
l'inflation n'en finit pas mauvais non
mais tu as le deuxième tour va vraiment
être intéressant de la compétition c'est
vraiment chaud c'est comme en juillet on
s'est vraiment mauvaises entre 6,6 et
début juillet ça va être début juillet
je tout le temps un fonds voit ça après
je peux pas donner de noms mais en fait
il ya déjà des dates qui sont prévues
mais je sais qu'ils peuvent les re
déplacer mais oui oui non ce sera
intéressant bien évidemment il y aura le
les demi finales et finales de ce pitch
est féminin qui vont arriver aussi dans
la semaine c'est la semaine prochaine et
celle de demain 23 et 27 de mémoire 25
annoncés bientôt
non là ça va on peut enchaîner mais eux
du vrai notre guillemets speech est
bientôt ensuite je crois que c'est prévu
pour août ouais mais je crois que ils
ont une meilleure stratégie cette année
en fait ils ont réglé quand même un truc
c'est que les matchs vont beaucoup plus
enchaîné que les années précédentes
attendez ça crie à nathan il m'attend et
chutait quant au maintien jeu + 12 28
ans mathématiquement c'est déjà quasi
fini en fait parce que 12 devrait comme
jeudi 10 parties en bullet c'est déjà
bien 11 se serait déjà beau mais d'où ça
me paraît impossible surtout s'il veut
vraiment faire afin qu ami ben en fait
est que tu la pendule ça lui demanderait
de joué que trente 30 coups par parti qu
enfin c'est facile ça c'est fou quoi
palmarès j'étais pris tad quill arend il
est vraiment fort moroni mais en fait
est vraiment fort est en réalité non
mais ils vont payer quasiment 2006 entre
8 580 par l'amour au niveau nous dire
son amour ni filet le fait est recherche
de profils donc moroni la 25,61 donc là
peu moins que ce que j'ai pu en 2000
donc il a aidé à 19 ans c'est pas mal
sur mance rageur à 2600 etc
tu vas pas ce sera le genre de joueur
qui je devrais le national en france
donc c'est pas c'est un charlot hic
c'est que tu joues avec plus fort que
toi et tu joues trop de partis en fait
j'en profite pour inciter les gens à
follow la chaîne d'ailleurs ouais bah
faut la chaîne si vous êtes là pour pour
la première fois favre ont fait une
petite pause vas-y petite pause dans
cinq minutes
ouais à les atrides
[Musique]
ouais je suis de retour fab et on
maigrit quoi on m'écrit quoi dans le
chat c'est la poste qui met les pubs
pendant qu on te suit on perd des partis
car c'est en mode non-stop
j'ai pas trop compris funky fm mais oui
mais je mets la pub prendre entre les
parties en fait - rhodia que deux pauses
ouais comme sinon ça joue au foot est
bon 3 minutes de pub après 1h30 de
programmer trois minutes de pub après
une heure de programme ont cédé demande
autre chose comme 1 c'est pas forcément
vous qui moi qui décide mais ça me
paraît pas non plus tu vois ça fait
partie ouais c'est reparti côté peinture
française du jeu mais revendent des
choses contre et contre moroni donc
bullet fab sans enjeu j'ai envie de dire
malheureusement signé 0 on va pas non
plus se surexcité et faire semblant que
tu n'y as dû te dire un suspense ouais
parce que 20 problème ces crises si on
fait trop de fake après sa paire
l'intérêt des commentaires en général
perdront l'intérêt donc on va suivre ça
tranquillement cette foulée 4 ici
objectif le truc c'est que l'on en fait
je vais regarder à quel moment le match
est fini mathématiquement quoi je suis
très d'accord même prend peut-être
bougeront du coup il est moins bien par
nous il a déjà vu pire écoute je pense
pas qu'ils sont obligés de faire le truc
ça la grille tchouk pour qui ce match
moscou qui voit son plus bas seraient
battus à la mine de rien ce que chez
elle est partie faire une partie de
moins de trois minutes en fête en
puissance et chaud non c'est faux trouve
aussi dans l'étrange et h5 bien joué je
pense non mais le truc c'est que renoir
va être un peu bizarre telle attaque
tattoo
un marque personnalisée de l'hôte et de
l'autre de 3 mais bon ça c'est quand
même au pied en version améliorée armées
royales des six noms mais là on est plus
mieux après ce message où on est
vraiment bien mais dommage parce que ça
ça va quand même une très bonne cet
endroit est finie quelques coups et le
lay a plus rien bon à moins que le
pillage 4 puis 7 faible quand on ramène
le roi toujours une possibilité mais
vous dire qu'il dit 6 4 gigas il ya
quand même 1200 personnes qui sont
barrées depuis s est pas ce qu on a
sûrement perdu la première page de long
et 2 et pas à cause de la cuve moment
mais vous avez beaucoup de mal je crois
comprendre que ces histoires première
page on peut nager j'ai remarqué qu il
ya une première page donc les gens de se
connecte sur twitch ils vont venir voir
ce qui se passe ils ont pas grand
intérêt et chaque ou quoi elle peut
importe donc il veut repartir ou quoi
cette crainte flux donc une masse des
spectateurs constante
donc en fait quoi qui se passent vos
spots des échecs ça pourrait être un
bonhomme de paille sera pareil et il
parcourt dhr après c'est les gens qui
restent basses qui courent bah oui oui
mais du coup je leur en ai millemont
nîmes il quand c'est vrai milan fait
c'est vraiment mille personnes qui sont
qui sont restés après il y en a quelques
uns qui sont perdus pas partie pendant
la pub mais bon tu peux pas tu veux pas
te reprocher aux gens de partir je passe
comme un oeuf allemagne pour brésil
allemagne ya déjà 6 0 face à autre chose
à faire oui tu as peur grimal jusqu'à la
fin pour montana non il y aura pas de
remonte à dax le match est plié donc
donc ouais c'est comme ça quoi mais il
va peut-être la gagne et quand même avec
les blancs quoique on va être un peu en
retrait comme auteur avec le fourgon de
cavaliers ou les noirs et les noirs
portés de faire un blocage avec
lecavalier et blanc ont droit aussi de
faire la différence à l'est la belle
dame mélodrame elle fonce et huit par là
bas puis débloqué le roi
et cette fois c'est un bonbon purement
nombre de cas si le fait qu'il soit
parti manque le match pas terrible mais
en fait ils sont pas forcément partie en
fait c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre ce
qu'ils te donne
il était peut-être jamais l'arrêt en
fait c'est fait ils partent pas c'est
juste des gens qui sont dans le flux et
qui serait partie mais juste avec lui
ils sont aussi vite remplacé qu'ils sont
partis en fait juste ça ils n'ont pas
été remplacés
ils sont pas partis ça fait vraiment
bien le comprendre en fait et tu vois un
câble bon là il va gagner quand même
deux jeunes aiment les autres têtes sur
son plateau bien mais pour les gens qui
sont là pour pour la première fois
évidemment vous êtes vraiment tombé sur
le mauvais match
voilà là je pense que vous êtes tombé
sur le couple a eu des bons matchs cette
saison ses rangs le pire match de la
saison sur lesquels je vais tomber le
moins dangereux
e.on à la base mais un pote justin qui a
écrasé l'autre en fait on va regarder la
première partie elle a duré combien de
temps à peu près parce qu'il ya un
décalage en plus avec l'image habituelle
à elle a duré quatre minutes la première
partie laissé 30 minutes son but le
trait le maxi partie match event
d'amendé c'est déjà faire du match
roddick ou si tu fais un coup dur oui si
tu veux le faire c'est perdu je pense
bah oui on nous on aime bien savoir
quand c'est vraiment fini quoi bas
depuis depuis poursuit fitch sur votre
toit ce délire je vous dirais qu'on a au
début les la séquence diaye une saison
c'est la deuxième saison en saison
précédente où on avait une saison juste
horrible où vous souhaitez ou ces termes
être tort car nature carnage ouais c'est
pas la saison dernière ça si si je crois
- des super heureux du match 12 heures
et choukook way et cardiaques hinduja
aussi ouais mais fait que 12 ans parce
que
des petits poussins pl ouais il avait et
donc que sté c'était sympa de voir un
joueur zerg durno un plat tour et est
donc ouais on était contents qu'ils en
russie se défendre super bien les
parties étaient animés et il y avait du
suspense
et puis on pense à chaque fois qu'elle
soit remontée qui a fait un exploit une
fois mais il refera pas appuyé en fait
chaque fois ils se battent à fou oui oui
c'était c'était sympa et même le match
contre socke il avait perdu on y avait
cru on espérait clairement de l'an
bullet et où on était chauds bref c'est
lui qui avait on pas fait la saison
l'année dernière mais tu as exactement
notre côté d'accueil il ratiboiser tout
gagné 29 un autre où il fait en outre
comme ça après après il ya quand même eu
la finale contre socke était beaucoup
plus serré que prévu suite rapa nui
ouais ouais ouais mais mais on m'a dit
quoi oui oui mais bon on y en a un dont
on pense et ce sera un massacre match il
ya eu match on sentait naka plus fort
mais on disait tu assures pareille
aurait pu aurait pu se passer quelque
chose mais euh ouais là là mais là c'est
aussi dans le contenu le truc c'est que
c'était non seulement c'est non
seulement un match à sens unique mais en
plus y'a pas une partie très
spectaculaire
non c'est très bon comme je vote blanc
est parti ou à des styles d'arts et
images un poste intéressant niveau
chaque coup il joue avec les blancs et
les a très bien traités notre mieux pain
parce que j'ai un commentaire de vlad
sur la perte d'une chouf au nord où est
chasseur j'ai parlé avec vannes avant le
norwich s il m'a clairement fait
comprendre qu'il en avait absolument
rien à faire de ce tournoi
donc en gros il en reparlera sûrement
quand on commentera les grand prix fina
en gros le commentaire c'est que c'est
un tournoi qui sert à rien et que là
pour prendre l'argent des organisateurs
et gris tout qu'il le dit il le dit même
directement là il n'a pas dit pour ce
tournoi mais la veillée à cham cuir qui
est un tournoi du même du même acabit
quoi c'est toi qui servent à rien quoi
vraiment mais surtout contre ses données
comme sauter les candidats qualifiés
regarde qu'eux en mode bridge ou qu'il a
il est
les grand prix iaaf et finaliste il a
gagné deux matches avant les rapides
donc il a marqué deux points de bonus au
décès de paul classement général donc en
gros pour lui l'objectif c'est de
refaire un autre très bon grand prix et
ça va le qualifier donc en fait s'il a
juste eu quelques prépa mais juste yves
les entreprises n'ont que ces patronymes
alignés bah oui ça fait quand les autres
on sait tous fin des prépas tu les as tu
les usa et puis après fort bossé comme
un fou pour retrouver visé même pas sûr
tu les retrouves bassin
donc là en fait il doit juste ne pas
jouer son répertoire non déjà maman de
jour c'est très dur de gagner une partie
mais alors là en bon ben voilà il
joueurs on dit donc c'est un truc qu'on
fait ça sert le tour assez rare ils
servent au jour à gagner leur pain bat a
tout résumé mais en fait comme tu peux
gagner ton pas en faisant des nuls en
dix coups de bol du coup tu fais ça sert
aujourd'hui à leur faim et c'est tant
mieux fasse aimer mais en tant que
spectateur en fait c'est rien en fait
c'est comme s'ils regardent enfin prête
à des gens qui kiffent tellement le foot
ils gardent les mêmes les matches
amicaux mais mais faut vraiment être
passionné de chez passionné parce qu'il
n'y a pas d'enjeu du tout non plus se
jouait pas des masses profondes zeppelin
devenue là j'ai perdu ouais ça faisait
plus rapide et tout ce que tu as et pas
en mode ça sert à rien c'est un tournoi
de gala sorte à des tatas des tournois
qui servent à rien pas forcément un
échec mais dans d'autres disciplines
mais où c'est en mode gala en mode on
envoie du jeu c'est à des bosniens et
ouais tu fais tu fais le spectacle quoi
donc ça c'est une chose mais là c'est en
mode ça sert à rien mais en mode
gestionnaire c'est que ça sert à rien
mais en fait on veut pas perdre quand
même ouais donc on regarde le point
l'eau affirme sûrs et puis on s'explique
en armageddon on glisse à 50 points
ouais ça compte vraiment pour rien du
coup bon il a regagné mon écoute moroni
qui se relèvent un peu mais non ma
passion c'est fini pour le match après
oui bah c'est très bien pour lui c'est
gagner une session dans ce match puis
tout ça ça fera moins fait c'est à la
fin mais bon je suis passionné par amer
énervé avec un fard énervé y rigole
machin ils sont semi vouloir mais bon et
il a il a lâché la chaîne macho man il
reste à wil reste à plus 11
il reste 20 minutes
ça ça va donc de gaza quoi de
l'organiser tout samba je sais pas bon
après on enrage ils sont choisis selon
karl scène ils sont contraints
d'organiser un tournoi
non mais c'est une vraie question en
fait l'on veut de moi c'est qu'ils sont
je me suis souvent posé en fait à juste
à quoi ça sert en gros mais c'est vrai
que je peux pas vraiment je pense qu'ils
sont contents dans l'exacte tournant
parce que ça devient populaire les
échecs en norvège ils ont klaxonné
machin mais mais globalement en fait en
général à qousseir dans les intrants
d'échec que financièrement pour
l'ordinateur c'est ça c'est une vraie
question c'est quoi le modèle économique
dans les échecs tout ça est dur à dire
peut-être qui a aidé cette pièce est
simple ok mais autant tu fais dans
d'autres sports tu vas vendre des places
de matchs des droits télés des machins
exterio tiens je sais pas comment ça
marche
non mais je crois qu'il ya juste donc ça
marche sur pas mal de mécénat des choses
comme ça mais il faut pas chercher le
sens derrière sa rentabilité en fait
mais c'est le problème fin j'ai souvent
parlé notamment quand je bosse à la fidh
que c'est un des problèmes en fait fait
si tu veux faire quelque chose devient
faut avoir un objectif s'ajuste pas
d'objectif c'est juste comme ça parce
que tu as de l'argent à dépenser
dépenser ou quoi c'est pas ben qui dit
mieux ouais enfin c'est de là provient
du pnue à temps s'il ya 1,2 milliard et
demi à 4 4 nuls qu'est ce qui nous
attend qu'est ce qu'il a vu moi je veux
voir une offre française si ces épreuves
il s'adonne qu à la fin mai pour y
réfléchit maintenant comme ça je
comprends rien ce match en fait depuis
le début soit 10 955 euros peut-on
davout ressort forcément la fille quatre
points 112 15 et ça suffit non mais tu
as le match et même été bizarre dans son
rythme en général non oui du moment de
réflexion est très bizarre c
et alors est ce que c'est parce qu'il ya
une mauvaise connexion etc en fait s'il
n'y avait pas les moins réfléchi
justement déconnecté prend les quatre et
ça va raser mais alors oui je parle du
clip même les open en fait quand tu es
en détendant eu au moins il ya des gens
qui s'inscrivent dans le tournoi des six
nations
tu fais ta buvette et machin ça fait des
choses donc là en fait ça ça va tu te
rembourse tu fais des trucs et les
commerces locaux tu donnes un peu
d'argent pour seulement seul tournoi et
eux sont contents de l'activité dans la
vie il est vendu à partir des places de
des gens on est en resto acheter des
trucs des souvenirs experts acteurs donc
ça je peux comprendre en fait nous parle
des super tournoi où les joueurs ont des
filles plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'euros pour commencer où les prix sont
gros et toute façon tu as trois
spectateurs qu'on aime un truc et voilà
et atterrit médias machin maton
il a raté un matin en un mot rené hawiyé
de match mais je sens qu'il peut la
gagner parce que tard et c'est dommage
je rate un m'attendais quand même de me
prendre la roue gagne pas c'est cool
mais qu'il était sur le fil mais je
crois en la collection très mauvaise
réponse pour paramount sa part est
problématique dans un autre match
notre déménager c'est quand les phases
qualificatives championnat du monde de
960 organisé par chase points comme
assez en ce moment tu as plus ou moins
raté c'était pas titré à l'eau chaude
keshi me fait notre fille de bella pour
le pousse pas du tout et on la fille
dont on parle ne tombât privé c'est la
fidh s'est pas trop mal ce qu'ils font
en jetant ils font les grands prix mais
là ça a du sens ces qualificatifs ils
font la coupe du monde ils ont fermé les
armageddon récemment au losc pas trop
critiquer en ce moment non autant on
apparaît et critiquer autant assez bien
ce qu'ils font franchement franchement
pour une fois tu vois c'est il commence
à faire des trucs bien failli commence à
faire ce dont parlait depuis longtemps
donc on va pas critiquer du tout quoi
ils m'ont les ont un système ils font
les tournois rapide quand c'est d'être
on a justement sans enjeu entre
guillemets donc c'est plutôt une bonne
idée du coup ils font ils font les
matches à élimination directe quand sade
l'enjeu c'est une bonne idée
et en gros ce qu'ils font c'est bien
donc non mais la densité en prison après
été privés de fait ce que ton argent
fait ça ne regarde pas spécialement quoi
mais j'ai le droit dépenses comme tu
veux bordel j'ai le droit serait génial
tu parles de ça on évite d'en prendre
cinq petites fenêtres film mais du coup
en tant que spectateur on a le droit de
ne pas être passionné aussi un par ces
trucs on à droite par regarder le droit
dans les deux sens mais après oui après
ils font leurs emballages faut voir que
c'est un truc de fou fantastique ou non
oui ils te font croire que c'est c'est
génial quoi ce qu'ils ont un
confessionnal et machin vous vivez vous
cette fin elle vous confesser ailleurs
alors comment il va gagner 4 donc on a
attaqué à 2,4 à 3,5 ou n'attaque que ce
n'est pas toujours le oui lui reste on
leur aurait promis à risque de temps fab
pour pour officialiser le gênant il ya
quinze minutes encore même si plus 10 en
15 minutes ça paraît sympa ça va à
l'image du doigt plutôt resté 14 30 que
15 mai puis le point un moteur très mal
avec le led du fou g73 peut-être à 3
l'arrêt il fonce voilà c'est fini
et donc la sarre fait plus eu 11 cha
moroni cas sensible même classement que
moi ambühl est déjà je me dis que en
bullet tu me ferait tellement défoncé
par parham mais vraiment sévère donc
ouais parham il a vraiment ralenti le
rythme le match gagné il a il a un peu
lâché quoi bon alors c'est vrai faut
dire que vers l'ombre de kfc c'est vrai
que dans certains tournois pour pour
combler un peu ce manque d'enjeu du coup
il invite des nouveaux pour forcer un
peu le combat parce que du coup comme
l'effort veulent pas perdre leurs points
hello bye bye est de gagner mais du coup
là ça devient sympa du coup ils donnent
de l'air du temps il ya un petit intérêt
certes ils te mettent des
duda il te mettre des rapports tôt ils
te mettent même des artemiev un an il
est monté mais il te mettais d art et
néophytes eux mettaient fight night des
jeunes prometteurs comme ça dans cette
plaine km/heure et du coup c'est bien
parce que dans toutes les rondes tata
atteinte à un combat où là il ya un
enjeu puisque mec n'est pas perdue
points elo il faut quand même gagné la
partie
et puis on a envie de voir les nouveaux
parce qu'en fait on voit que sur les
mêmes participants
si vous voilà là en fait ce qu'il chante
assise que c'était une haïti box et tu
vas avoir le glas t-box qui a fait que
des nuls enfin il est intéressant et qui
aura exactement les mêmes joueurs qui
vont jouer à deux trois exceptions près
qui ont une grande chez ce tour croatie
donc c'est pas cher c'est hallucinant en
fait
bah écoute non mais c'est triste et aux
ordinateurs dartybox et de grandes chez
ce tour de droit pour leur truc ça sonne
on n'y peut rien alors on n'y peut rien
mais c'est triste c'est triste mais mais
ouais mais pourquoi retenir j'ai même
pas trop qui était si éviter que ça dans
les gros tournois n'ont ils pas
s'inviter non je comprends voir des
ninjas et laggan et gibraltar oui mais
n'est que numéro 10 mondial on le voit
nulle part donc ça pourrait être
intéressant de le voir donc ne
l'invitons pas surtout à ça donnera un
intérêt à notre tournoi
du coup pas de chance quoi nous ne
l'avons pas d'égal que moi je reviens
loin pas ce qui m'impressionnait j'étais
là en voyage le voyage et c'est parti
était sympa quoi famille je veux pas
trop théorique il que c'est bien c'est
petit guide et il a aidé gitans il est
déjà dans ses variantes et il fait de
raser le temps a complètement quaglio
d'un la fin et puis bon il y avait quand
même fait n y avait qu à rouffach à mais
c'était très forte hausse et en face aux
ibères fort projet ouattara elle a été
invitée à pike offs qui attention
oui mais bon c'est un tournant s'entiche
au cinéma histoire seconde zone
ça atp 250 à la rigueur oui non c'est
encore meilleur c'est dommage qu'ils
sont invités pour paris kof qui que tu
sois pas invitée pour nous il faut votre
consentement des quatre les boums
d'apprendre le cavalier super fort
soutient l'option il ya des réseaux de
maths ficelle ou faire très vite peut
être pour enlever la dame voilà on
masque et 6 maintenant comme sessad
j'imagine tranquille et on va pousser à
l'âme
je te prends devers peut être mieux ne
pas très bien et il remonte à plus de
douze fab 12 il ya moins de 12 minutes
non le way c'est fini mathématiquement
c'est gagner mais tu es foutu ratant des
douze minutes quand même pour finir
assez at il commencé durant leur
refusent des cartes nombre de kiev mais
est ce que on peut pas faire des
tournages armageddon tout le temps mais
en fait l'armageddon enfin faut pas
faire moins de ravages dans le seul
intérêt cesser des tirs au but ont fait
la renommée dont donc doit faire des
trucs à élimination mais c'est le solde
ainsi donc si tu joues ta journée de
championnat ta amis animent
il y en a partout et aboutir à faire des
tirs au but canada par contre 5,4 de
france qui est fille pour la demie ok
c'est cool
km 128 tu seras quand même confronté au
même problème femmes dans tous les cas
avec ces tournois là c'est vous qui tue
alors fait une fois deux fois trois fois
ton système de couper avec armes à gaza
bon c'est très bien parce qu enfin voilà
en fait au quatrième tournoi comment
fais tu n'as aucun enjeu bah on en aura
deux nouveaux fut rien à faire non mais
bon pied non mais c'est pas assez car
enfin c'est comme si on ne passe du
djokovic-nadal dix fois par an en fait
je veux plus le voir ça ça m'intéresse
plus en fait ben ouais c'est celle de
l'us open ou un truc comme des finales
de wimbledon c'était choses intimes
nadal y en a combien dans l'année il l'a
battu
si vous êtes à madrid barcelone nos
personnages s'il a perdu roland garros
mais encore barcelone on s'en fout
temple oui mais bon c'est la préparation
nous on s'en fout il y en a eu deux dans
l'année il y en a pas eu dix et ont eu
de barcelone ça te fare d'indicateurs
des quatre hommes pourront lire aussi
c'est tout mais c'est pas un match que
j'ai spécialement khafaji même pas
regardé en fait mais bon je leur avais
regardé si j'avais pu je suis aussi je
veux le temps mais oui alors que la
finale d'un grand chelem route mais
c'est ça en fait des jo au canada cette
année on n'a pas encore eu un non alors
que des caruana 47 on a bouffé 12
du monde tuant rob huff là tu voir beauf
et dans une dent dans une nature l'homme
apple qu'annecy va tu vas pas michael j
encore il a pas que le grand duché
sourds a pu s'entendre bouffe et 3
fautes en a déjà fait dix dans l'année
la fio videmment c'est pas possible
quand même non non mais jamais ce qu'on
il federer nadal son jeu une fois la
lada un poste à miami un lien on y voit
un nom là mais c'est presque comme si
elle vous fait du caviar que tu vas nous
fait une fois deux fois trois fois mais
si je commence à t'en servir matin midi
et soir en fait au bout de deux semaines
tu vas venir mais dégage pas jeu en fait
tu vas être content tu vas te dégoûter
en fait ce qu'ils veulent de moi des
pins je préfère non mais en fait c'est
ce qu'ils font avec les échecs de haut
niveau c'est qu'en fait ils te dégoûte
en fait la force
en gros c'est ça non mais vraiment
femmes bas sans doute sur la même partie
en face rien d arthur a bien joué oui
une petite victoire pour momo il tient
le choc quand même plus on a tous moi
mais je pense que c'est soit connexion
soit je pense et connexions ou alors il
est pas si mauvais angle là qu'alain
grosse différence c'est laurent nous dit
il prolonge reçoit us ou 2 to soit 1 147
gardes ton titre aussi c'est quand même
le truc le plus probable en ce moment a
dit mme irène aussi à part le wedding il
fait pas de bruit mais là il se dit même
caruana faut pas longtemps il fait j
dellacqua passé qu'un numéro deux
mondial clairement j'ai peur des bons
temps d'un même là le tourneur norvège
il ya quand même fait plus à un
cadencement
il ya une façon de prendre et puis des
camps de carlson il a fait son match de
haut niveau
il a pas été dominés il faut était moins
bien des fois on était mieux qui est nul
sur les deux parties je pensais près
normale après c'est juste un rapide
qu'il a pris l'eau l'on sait qu'il est
pas terrible en rapide par rapport à son
niveau lente après ce qu'aime le
deuxième match consécutif de championnat
du monde qui se dessine en rapide oui
est-ce que c'est pas
inquiétant une tendance cédant des
parties price est vrai que c'est bizarre
ça fait déjà eu des nuls dans l'histoire
du monde mais ce que même la langue et
le fond dans tout ça c'est fini un
rapide ouais et donc s'il ya pas si
longtemps
donc c'était quand même 3 en moins d'une
décennie et une chronique topalov en
2006 donc en 15 en même temps que 13 en
paca 3 24 matchs et ilia kramnik l'écho
à brissago ti aurait dû à leur rapide
ouais il s'est juste pour nous mais au
moins vous êtes soumis deux victoires
deux défaites ils sont reprend une
tactique un petit fourchette par mail un
peu plus là et me vois pas dans
l'histoire oui il ya eu du tout comme
douzy de lebron stein d'un beau binic 51
je pense
il ya une carte preuve kasparov sévit 87
mais je crois que c'est les seuls en
face au yen il s'est retenu deux matches
dans l'histoire du championnat du monde
donc tu poses de 30 1890 on va dire de
steinitz jusqu'à jusqu'à 2000 jusqu'à de
début des années 2000 on prend plus de
110 ans il ya eu que deux matchs seront
finis par dose ou enfin parvenu en tout
cas hélas trop souvent
ouais mais c'est la nature du jeu qui
change aussi nous en plus deux nuls en
général plus en plus dur de gagner un
heureusement qu'ils incarnent scène un
d'ailleurs pour gagner ouais bah après
ben et des joueurs qui vint will say to
sont atteints je peux pas leur jeter la
pierre
ça c'est tout de très fort joueur mais
le problème c'est que c'est juste dur
quand il ya du répondant en face il a
pris pas mal mais qui connaît la vente
de leur dit l'autre aussi bas il récite
et puis ma fille défend bien et ça
défend pas mal exactement
mieux qu'avant klein avance à défendre
est pas très bien qu'on parle
aujourd'hui c'est en fait la plus grosse
différence
r oui oui nous avons exactement non mais
genre tu vois les finales de rubinstein
qui sont excellentes
c'est si ça je me disais une fiancée va
être très chiant novacarb rex et rex 3
qui arrive on peut pas je crois pas
qu'on puisse et on peut peut-être ans de
retard et ses 36 ans vient mais ouais
des finales de rubinstein
en fait les mecs défendent est très très
mal quoi défense passive a j'ai perdu
mais bon le truc c'est qu'il ya besoin
de passer par cette étape pour qu'on
comprenne que défense passive c'est pas
bien et le mal dans sa chair mais donc
c'est l'évolution mais donc oui clarence
a défendu par des tremblements qui
m'arrivait utp après tout il mieux mieux
je partirai dissidia le pion à gérer
votre vie de contrôle portera sa non
plus sur toi ouais alors de 8 m
et c'est gagné
parham qui reprend +12 fab
mais petit a dit qin c'est chaud alors
quelques quelques ouvertures
c'est chaud
donc non mais en tout cas match beau
match de parham après 1 s'est il a
dominé de la tête au numérique
il mérite cette victoire ça mon genre de
jeu mais trop vu c'est parti zhu zhu
pets je savais qu'il était champion du
monde junior joue pas mal non
et là il doit mieux c'est une fois je
crois qu'ils arrivent guerre qui prend
des cats fait kg 3 un hacker prend 1,4
et le voir partir de roches fuite et ont
vu partir avec le full sophos hot 100
verse aux banques et des gâteaux et
alpilles en c4 silva temps l'air aussi
plus partout oui ou non mais c'est
champion du monde juniors de toute façon
c'est pas de l'oim
non non non nous a peut-être a bien joué
bien jouer non pas par am c'est ça qui
est bien en se demandant ce speech à
junior parce qu'on découvre des joueurs
dont on a entendu parler mais qu'on
al'occasion du coup de voir jouer sur la
durée ça c'est quand même c'est quand
même intéressante que tu as même sevian
sarine tout ça je n'ai jamais vraiment
dû jouer aussi longtemps
l'atuge c'est à dire moi j'avais joué
contre lui quand j'avais fait on trouve
à washington a fait nul non jeff est nul
j'avais les blancs s'étaient pas
glorieux mais non il est bon niveau dans
la zone tous ces mecs sont du grand
maître très jeune général c'est quand
même qu'ils ont un talent donc même si
après vous n'êtes pas plus que ça ou
quoi il on y voit vite les trucs ils
sont doués pour les échecs quoi ouais
mais si tu as non mais c'est sûr c'est
sûr c'est sûr ils sont bon quoi
forcément après i'm à 7 francs même si
ces cavaliers j'espère juste ne pouvait
pas le faire fin de l'an 17 et prend la
8c domine j'avais l'impression que ça
marche et en salle à d'autres
mais cette fois-ci temps je peux te dire
je présiderai fille bon c'est vrai c'est
la dernière partir de dire une bêtise ou
skeets sur une bonne note en tout cas et
c'est un match c'est un match
intéressant pour le joueur iranien
trouvé ça tout ils ne peuvent pas tout
faire
soit fois ci c'est exactement où kelly
lynch pour bloquer le truc après les
joueurs sont fatigués aussi fable
méfiance et pince tuerie a dit j'ai déjà
commenté des matches qui sont finis au
final à +9 +10 en étant serré juste à la
fin je pense justement d'heure le match
sarine je crois que au final ça finit
avec un score un peu cruel un peu sévère
mais juste parce qu'ils craquent sur les
intrigues sur deux segments mais le
dernier il a craqué petit à petit dans
le match l'autre a pris le dessus
mais là c'est marrant parce qu'au final
ça finira plus ça finira plus +12 +14
+13 mais je dirais que tu as ta des
matchs avec un scénario beaucoup plus
serré qui sont finis avec un score plus
sévère
ouais non mais là en fait après deux
parties on savait déjà
ouais on savait avant là pour suspecter
grandement suspects est ce qu'on veut
mais après deux parties s'étaient juste
vérifier après on s'est trompé il faut
attraper je crois que c'était le match
de dakar yakine away mais google nous
avait perçu recrutement des comptes
entre autres on peut mais on pensait au
début de match je pense karekin prend le
dessus et on dit bon c'est fini en fait
da qui revient petit à petit et fait on
n'y croyait pas
non
et puis reprend plus si les immigrés
tout et tout mais c'était tellement
surprenant ce match et ont dit oui moi
c'est tout havas faire massacrer comme
tout le monde na na na tu vas en était
le haut des médisants du coup on l'a
recruté en pro che ce link pour le
recruter il a été bon ben on a fait du
scoutisme pendant les portes de ce pitch
est ce vous cherchez des pépites et où
je pense parham pas la perdre ça l'a été
bien déconnecté du coup à mon avis va la
perdre pas qu'ils soient moins bien ou
quoi mais j'ai l'impression qu'ils
soient hyper un peu sa connexion mais
l'autre aussi pas du tout par la
collection torse et si ce bateau c'est
ce qui attend plus que la tour pas si
vite c'est très bien mais je pense
surtout qu'il va un peu près bouffer ce
qui se passe a requis une connexion de
merde avec les blancs oui il se remonte
la très bien pacifier le tour des cinq
faut faire tomber huit danseuses
collection qui marchent à voir avec les
cultes emprunt si ce montant vite se
passait bien naturel bien je ne
travaille matin un plus ou un pion
précisent qu'ils ne foulent en évitant
tant points 6e partir ailleurs apprécié
en a c'est génial il ya du prix mauvais
temps feront le show ouais
nous avons un bon ballon je passe sur
internet notamment à cette donne des 400
environ deux ans
je sais par contre c'est nul je sais pas
je peux au courant de la minul ob 6
revient là c'est nul c'est sûr ami adam
prend à cette option et emprises la
dérobée satan vous exprimer laférois c6
il a mis d'accord bah si on joue des
coûts normaux
madame ok c'est fini c'est fini sur le
score de 20 à 7
plus 13 way écoute bombe un peu trop de
suspens selon mme parham sera un
candidat pour les sorties de la sauce
direct ses fans d'internet comme si vous
déjà d'ailleurs doit déménager les
gommes les deux les deux qui doivent et
oui et oui oui mais si on fait tous les
sens paris on touche le fond de teint
nous y dort équilibrer les matchs ou
alors pire at war collection mais bon ça
suffit pas on écoute moi j'aime être une
page de pub je vais faire un petit pot
stream sur la chaîne bitstream contre
pour jouer contre les mecs
ok ok les i go go joaquin moi je les
regardais un peu le les féminines jouent
au foot c'est no more pas et demain
demain un nouveau match alors un bon
acteur pour tahar 19h 19h ok bah écoutez
soyez nombreux
et moi je vous dis à bientôt à bientôt
fabas bientôt bas les gens moi je reste
juste 2000 ce qu'on fait je vois les
c'est le truc pour que la pub passe donc
cela pour le moment et on se bat
soissons se trouve here to dont nous
tous les noms à faire là
la vidéo sur l'actrice de dames c'est
qu'un jour dès que dès que mon granger
près de tucson au cours donc peut-être
deux jeunes à elle ou quoi ok fabre
alors attendez je vais récupérer ma clé
de stream pour pouvoir faire ce petit
post rythme au jeu quelques parties avec
vous à face à une petite heure va pas
faire le stream le plus long de l'année
mais voilà c'est pour pour un peu
profité comme un peu de monde il ya
peut-être des nouveaux qui veulent faire
quelques parties et puis le lundi soir
on a l'habitude de faire notre stream
donc j'aime bien garder les bonnes
habitudes d'habitude on joue de 21h30 à
22h30 l'on va faire on va faire un pain
un peu plus courants à peu près la même
chose quoi
et donc je vais vous préparer ça alors
je sais pas combien de temps ça me
prendre à m disons que je sais pas si je
peux si je peux mettre le truc
du coup je vais je vais je vais quitter
le live ici et je vais mettre un raid
tout bêtement et on se retrouve tout de
suite à toufik les mecs